so John fetterman the Democrat senator
from Pennsylvania apparently signed on
to some to some legislation and drafted
a letter despite the fact he's been
hospitalized for two weeks and no one
has seen him since and his wife and
children have fled the country okay fled
they went on vacation and federman's in
the hospital for depression the rumor
that's going around is that he's brain
dead or close to it
I don't know if that's true but the dude
was already suffering from some severe
debilitating effects of a stroke so if
the guy disappears for two weeks no
one's heard from him I'm not so sure
depression is the simple solution that
makes the least amount of assumptions
especially when his family dips out of
the country for vacation but you know
who knows maybe the guy's just chilling
and he's depressed or whatever right
after winning the biggest race of his
life and accomplishing his dreams he's
sad now I don't know for all we know
like he got his dreams and then he's
like I can't function and he really is
depressed but the rumor going around is
that he's just no longer functioning
near brain dead and there are even some
Republicans demanding Proof of Life
maybe a bit uh exaggerated but a lot of
people are wondering how did he sign on
to this legislation if he's currently
admitted to a hospital and not working
all right let's talk about it then we
got Joe Biden who laughed when
discussing a story about a mother whose
two two children died when they
accidentally ingested Fentanyl and
Kareem Jean-Pierre says no no he's being
sympathetic to the family of course of
course Biden blames Trump here's what I
love about the story Donald Trump
inherits a busted border from Obama and
Biden and immediately his whole campaign
was building a wall to stop these
problems immediately starts deporting
people and trying to build a wall which
is blocked by democrats and now you have
Joe Biden saying oh no that was Trump's
fault that was during the Trump
Administration all right let's talk
about the Border crisis there's a bunch
of other stories of course we can get to
there's a Tennessee lawmaker who wants
to bring back hanging people by a tree
as a method of execution well all right
I guess that seems to be where we're
going before we get started head over to
timcast.com click that join us button to
become a member we're gonna have a
members only show coming up tonight
uncensored not so family friendly and we
do those live now
so a lot of people said we shouldn't use
Discord because they'll ban us and we
should use gilded and then we found out
gilded's rules are actually crazier and
it's probably worse so now we're going
back to the Discord but it is nearly
done
so here's what we're going to do once we
have the Discord set up solution we'll
set the YouTube chat back to the normal
chat and then we will consolidate
memberships if you are a member at
timcast.com to give you access to the
Discord to chat there so there will be
the functioning member chat and the open
wild YouTube spam whatever you want to
do and we'll probably just let people do
whatever they want on the YouTube chat
within you know whatever YouTube lets
them do to be honest so become a member
and then watch the live show after the
live show at timcast.com that goes up
around 10 10 p.m we said the live stream
we get it going and then you can hang
out on the website where we cuss and
make jokes and talk about naughty
stories so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about this and so much more is
Ashley Sinclair hello hello thanks for
having me again Tim absolutely who are
you what do you do I am I do uh
operations for the Babylon bee and I am
also an author of the anti-trans
children's book elephants are not Birds
another story that we should talk about
is this viral video of drag for babies
there's viral video going around where
there's literally babies I'm not
exaggerating babies on the ground as a
guy does a thong striptease and there's
like disco lights going off yo it should
be criminal yeah it should be criminal
well do not passcode do not like 200
that's in London but I'm pretty sure
it's already illegal it's just cops
we'll get into we'll get into it also
joining us tonight is Mary Morgan hello
everyone it's been a while since I've
been on IRL my name is Mary Morgan why
is my voice shot
um I'm on pop culture crisis here in the
attic at timcast and I was let out today
that's right in the Attic happy to be
here maybe it's your meat diet yeah yeah
you've been on the carnivore diet
recently
um still adjusting I feel like I don't
really want food anymore I'm just
repulsed by it now all right you're on
the right track
is that a good sign I don't know
something like that uh Ashley you said
you're you put anti-trans and air quotes
when you were describing your books they
say about it so that's the criticism but
the book itself is about you are what
you are be happy they're not Birds boys
are not girls girls are not boys hi
everyone Ian crossing here happy to be
here good to see you again Ashley Mary
good to see you hi Serge what's
happening Brother yo uh oh you're my
microphones are far away from your phone
I'm just not talking into it
um yeah ready to start the show let's
jump into this first story we got this
from the post millennial John fetterman
co-sponsor Senate Bill despite being
institutionalized since February 15th
Letterman's office has not said who is
co-sponsoring legislation with his name
on it while he remains institutionalized
a senior aide revealed that fetterman
would be hospitalized for up to two
months so it's clearly not him I guess
that's the important point is they're
saying he's co-sponsoring this bill but
it's probably just a member of his staff
and uh I gotta show you this right here
from Twitter
or from John cardillo on Twitter
he says this is from February 25th it
was a while ago being told that
fetterman is essentially brain uh brain
dead
and and uh let me let's start over being
told that fetamine is essentially brain
dead and it's being hidden because
keeping it in him in office until August
18th avoids a special election which
Republicans would most certainly win
this must be investigated so here's the
best part about this tweet there's the
the context gets added to it and it says
readers edit context they thought people
might want to know the August 18th date
is no significance if a senator from
Pennsylvania passes away a replacement
appointed by the governor will serve
until the next special election oh thank
you for the fact check Twitter no uh no
fact check on whether or not veterans
brain dead or not that one they didn't
so that's I saw that and I was like okay
the the a bunch of users said no no no
there won't be a special election he's
probably brain dead but they'll just you
know replace it the 18th doesn't matter
they'll just replace him or something so
is is fetterman brain they're not
debating the brain dead part right
that's what I thought was funny I'm like
you'd think they'd be like there's no
evidence to suggest that John fetterman
is effectively brain dead he was
institutionalized with depression that's
not really a medical term is it brain
dead I mean uh it might might be I don't
know and are they is this like a
cover-up of a suicide attempt no no
struggling with depression the
depression is probably fake I feel like
that's the big part yeah he's probably
in the hospital because his brain
doesn't work oh brain death is a thing
uh it's permanent irreversible and
complete loss of brain function except
for the brain stem right uh I don't know
the the part that controls breathing or
whatever but they do say it's
irreversible so you know let me let me
hyperbolic in this situation we'll we'll
do an informal poll of the of the
audience we'll ask the audience what is
more likely knowing fetterman's health
and medical history that he is depressed
after winning you know his dream
election and checked himself into a
hospital where he'll be for up to two
months or the man who suffered a stroke
not that long ago and still can't
understand words had some kind of
recurring health issue that has injured
his brain further I think that
depression put a one in the chat if you
think he's just depressed and two if you
think he's brain does I I think the
Democrat Party is the worst senior care
home I've ever seen I mean between
fetterman and Biden they cannot find out
I mean they never know where these guys
are how do we not know where John
fetterman is I don't know how do we not
know if he's brain dead
well you know I'm always I always I
always roll my eyes a little bit at
stuff like this it is convenient for
conservatives in the right to be able to
say he's brain dead because the dude's
basically not around so in the world of
politics this is
I don't know par for the course guy goes
to the hospital immediately come out
with some salacious rumor that's going
to shock and damage the perception of
this party but I'm kind of like of all
the rumors they could have the dude who
had a stroke not that long ago who can't
understand words suffering another
stroke is completely plausible because
we talked about this before people who
suffer Strokes are at risk for suffering
them again and then all of a sudden
dudes in the hospital for several weeks
and get this his wife is gone Giselle
fetterman children take trip to Canada
in Wake of senators hospitalization
rightful looking woman that's what gets
me even if he's not brain dead right
what in what world when anyone you care
about is hospitalized because they're so
depressed do you flee the country
I think people were ragging on her
and a lot of uh like on Twitter they're
like stop making fun of fetterman's wife
you're you're bad people and it's like
dude her husband's depressed and in the
hospital for weeks and she just went on
vacation with her kids that is like that
that's worse than what Ted Cruz did like
with Ted Cruz he went on vacation during
that ice storm and it's like well he was
with his family though you know so at
the very least he cares about his family
this is like the sender's wife whose
husband is a senator not only fleeing
the state but also fleeing her husband
who is you know convalesced that's dark
if he's just depressed then what is the
reason to hospitalize unless they think
that he's a danger to himself
like I don't know I guess he checked
himself in if you're if you're depressed
that's the last like a Hospital's last
place you should be and
they would just ship you off to a
long-term medical facility that's not
hospital this guy's a cucumber he's a
cucumber it just doesn't add up to me
and they assign him this authoritarian
looking school teacher woman everybody
thought Ruth Bader Ginsburg died that
one time they're like where is she she's
dead and then she pops up a few months
later like I'm still here and you know
and so I wouldn't be surprised if
fetterman you know pops up later because
you can't if someone really was brain
dead then they can't keep that covered
up forever so I I wonder if he's I think
injury makes more sense recurring injury
makes more sense but I don't know about
brain dead I think the depression makes
a lot of sense whenever someone uh
suffers a head trauma especially
Fighters it's pretty common in the fight
they be they have all sorts of chemical
imbalance a lot of bad things can happen
emotionally to people with head trauma
so if he had a stroke it's very likely
that confusion brings on depression
maybe that lead could have led to stress
additionally could have led to another
episode or another injury as well but I
I wouldn't I I think the depression for
sure what's what's that thing he's got
where he can't understand words anymore
that was that was the big thing like he
can hear when you talk but all he hears
is like
and so he that's problematic it's very
yeah so during during the debates there
was a monitor and when they would talk
it would translate the text to speech so
they could look at it and then read it
and it was causing him problems yeah he
had the cheat screen I wonder if just it
got to the point where he's in office he
just can't do the job and none of us
thought he could do the job
and so you know he's like so humiliating
maybe look if he is in the hospital
I would I would say this if it's not a
recurring injury then it's political and
they probably said we can't work with
you because your brain's broken go to
the hospital and take a few weeks to see
if you can get your head straight and
we'll have your AIDS take care of the
job for you and we'll send your wife too
Canada Canada
in the winter is a great does she have
family there maybe she got family there
uh here's the story from Penn Live what
happens when your husband or father a
senator to boot checks into the hospital
and media truck Circle your home packed
the kids up and head to Canada Giselle
fetterman says fetterman recently
explained on Twitter that she and her
kid and her kids left Pennsylvania for a
family trip to Niagara Falls to get away
from the media coverage surrounding her
husband's recovery at Walter Reed
Medical Center in Washington DC
fetterman checked himself in to receive
treatment for clinical depression on
February 16th according to his chief of
staff Adam gentelson he is there on a
voluntary basis while his family
navigates how to deal with the grief
that comes with such a hospitalization
Giselle fetterman said she and her son
ziplined across Niagara Falls and the
family did other scary things together
this is just a really really weird story
isn't it it sounds sick it sounds sick
what
he's leaving him oh I could see that
going to the hospital room and he's like
incapacitated almost like uh and but
he's like I want you to be happy kind of
thing like do it I would go she's like
okay we'll do it we'll go ziplining over
Niagara Falls
like voice generator you can talk no you
just can't understand the words that are
said to him I don't know he could be in
a coma for all I know I don't know
that's the reason I don't know remember
when Trump got coveted and everyone was
like oh he's dying he's dying they're
covering it up
um
all the establishment journalists who
didn't want to seem like they were
establishment were like I hope he dies
like they're really ugly people I want
the best for John fetterman I want him
to be healthy which is why I wanted him
to lose because no person that just got
a had a stroke should be taking on that
kind of mental stress and obviously and
this is why because it's the same thing
with Joe Biden I genuinely feel bad for
both Joe Biden and fetterman I feel like
it's elder abuse what they're doing Joe
is putting them through the ringer
Feinstein's in the hospital right now
but that's shingle yeah but but still
like how old is she how can someone look
up her age so okay so we didn't even
bring this up we should have mentioned
this Diane Feinstein's in the hospital
the Democratic party is you know with
all due respect to the elderly the
geriatric party at this point at least
Republicans have like you know that
they're making fun of the Republican
party in CPAC for the weirdos and the
freaks you had Joe Scarborough on MSNBC
call them all weirdos and freaks and I'm
like at least they're like young ish
dude
she's gonna be 90 in June wow and Nancy
Pelosi is still in office it's just a
whole bunch of really old people that
are slowly dying a democratic and and
young leftists don't like the Democratic
party so this could finally be the end
of this garbage political party limits I
need term limits I agree you know what
about wait wait I got it party term
limits
I mean you gotta change parties at some
point a Democrat cannot hold the same
office longer than two consecutive terms
or something like that unless they
become a republican so like no no any
party so we do this if this any any seat
a senator seat a congressional seat is
held by a Democrat for you know like
let's say term limits member of Congress
they can serve eight years after those
eight years you can't have the same
person or political party
oh you got to switch the whole thing up
well you know what I think I think they
should remove the D's and the R's on all
of the ballots agreed it should be
illegal that way because people will
change their name like hot lightning and
stuff and they'll get or like Aaron
Anderson
they'll be like if you can't you know if
you've got to represent yourself just
buy a piece of text on a paper when the
vote comes to stupid voters or people
that ignore John Democrat Smith yeah
they'll be like best choice would be the
name and they'll be like how does Best
Choice keep winning the elections these
nuts I'm kind of joking but I'm
concerned that just taking the D and the
RF wouldn't be enough because they'd
still understand it is a start you have
to put your legal name so we went to
Congress uh a month ago and we spent
some time on their interviews real quick
sorry correction we're not there this
week we're there next next Friday
um we interviewed them and I got a Vibe
of why they don't want seem to want
terminal and it's why there's pushback
because it's like a fraternity you go in
and they become such close tight battle
buddies good friends that like it's
almost like losing an arm to see one of
them have to go like Lauren bobert Matt
Gates like they're tight and if all of a
sudden Lauren disappears it's like dude
that's like part of our crew man it's
not just that they have to build their
offices when when we went there they
were explaining how you get an office
and then you have to do Remodeling and
you've got to set it up they give you
space that's all you get and the staff
is all integrated with people of other
staffs and stuff it's it's it's but you
know just that's not enough reason to
not have term limits in my opinion I
just see why there's resistance to it
party term limits and bureaucrat term
limits
I think the party term limit thing is we
could even one-up it and say
a Democrat a a member of a party or I
should say a political party cannot have
a member serve
uh within like we do a gap term so if a
Democrat is in office for eight terms
then it can't be a Democrat for the next
eight terms
and it could only be so so basically
yeah that is after that it can be the
Democrats again so there's eight years
where it's not the Democratic party that
means they'll have to be a third party
because if a Democrat district has their
person term out they're not going to
vote Republican so it's got to be a
different political party and that could
mean there and there ends up with like
we end up with like four or five
different political parties that are
very similar but whatever I'll take it
break up the uh the duopoly of the
private political organizations that
control everything
[Music]
has that ever happened on Earth in any
government that the same party can't
hold power I don't know multiple terms
no idea let's uh let's rag on Joe Biden
how about that we got this story from
Fox News how dare you mother of two sons
who died from fentanyl demands Biden
apologize for laughing about her story
don't be a coward do something kiesling
said in response to President Biden so
here's the story
this woman had two of her sons die in in
summer of 2020 they took some pills they
thought were Percocet they were laced
with fentanyl they died she's very upset
about it and the drugs apparently came
over the southern border a problem for
which Donald Trump was trying to solve
and actually campaigned on solving in
2015 a problem that existed under the
Biden uh of the Obama Biden
Administration
so Marjorie Taylor green interviews this
woman Marjorie Taylor green then tweets
out basically Biden's policies resulted
in this and then like these people died
and then Biden when asked about it
starts laughing saying that was under
the other guy that was that was under
the Trump Administration
so she's pissed obviously her kids are
dead and the important point in this
whole story is that Donald Trump
inherits Joe Biden's administrator it's
Obama's administration but Biden's the
VP
trumpet at his campaigning in 2015 like
we got to secure the Border we got to
stop the drug cartels what happens the
media calls him racist
okay Biden the Biden Administration
comes back in after the fact the Border
collapses they they claimed When Donald
Trump was desperately trying to get
funding to build the wall that he was
racist and they shouldn't do it it
wouldn't work anyway
so here you have Joe Biden laughing that
these two kids who died died while Trump
was President despite the fact that
Trump was trying to fix the problem so I
imagine it like this Joe Biden and
Barack Obama are in charge of the fire
department when a bunch of fires erupt
and they don't do anything about it and
then Donald Trump says give me the
firehouse and I'll put the fire out
Trump then starts desperately spraying
these buildings trying to stop the fire
and then after a few years Biden comes
back takes it from him and then laughs
at all the people who died in that fire
yeah they were like are you anti-fire
Donald are you you fire phobic
yes I guess they said when when Trump is
like China's sending drugs they're like
you can't say that that's racist then
these kids die and Biden's like haha
that was Trump is there video of him
laughing oh yeah yeah he was giving a
speech uh I don't know he was laughing
in a malicious way he's just not present
of mine yeah I don't think he was doing
he wasn't necessarily laughing at the
woman he was laughing and mocking
Marjorie Taylor green but it's like the
context of it is Marjorie Taylor green
says these two young men died because of
these border policies and it's Biden's
fault and Biden's like no it wasn't
Trump was President it's like dude you
were the vice president before Trump got
in and Trump literally campaigned on
stopping a problem that was happening
under your Administration how can you
how do you blame Trump for that he
doesn't understand because Hunter knew
where to get the clean ones that's right
yeah he's got connections I think the
Democrats
are the party of short-term gains so
they will let the Border crisis keep
going if it gives them a short-term
benefit in terms of economic you know
but then he gives his State of the Union
Address and says well we got to fix the
crisis at the border we had over 70 000
fentanyl deaths
as if he actually cares when they're the
ones creating this problem and throwing
gasoline on the dumpster fire at the
border but he did say that at the state
of the union he pretended to care at
least for a moment can we just can I
just you know someone else wrote that
though Joe Joe Biden so
Joe Biden laughs at the story and it's
just it's it was a layup it was so easy
someone could have come to him and said
we got a really really great opportunity
to boost your approval rating it's
really really great this this Marjory
Taylor green is talking to this mother
whose children died he was the Border
crisis there's a perfect opportunity for
you to win some points all you got to do
is say
I'm so sorry to hear about what happened
to your children trust me when I say I
will do whatever it takes to seek
Justice and make sure we end the
fentanyl crisis we are working very hard
I'm sorry we let you down but trust me
we'll get the job done couldn't he just
do that like does he have anybody you
don't even have to mean it no I know
that's what I'm saying like just just
give us some empty platitudes about
trust me we're working hard no he left I
don't even need a plan nothing but look
look here's a guy who took a secret trip
to Ukraine with half a billion dollars
while the East Palestine crisis was
happening and there's toxic chemicals
spilling and he's just like well better
go to Ukraine that's that's what matters
you know to me I guess so I'm just kind
of bummed yeah I want to insult him
yeah I don't think it's an insult
prick I'm gonna call him um a dismissive
prick is what I want to call him but
like I've seen him just be like laugh
and dismiss people like oh come on Matt
Walsh would be proud uh and like he just
laughed and did did the whole dismissive
thing on Marjorie which is what this
sounds like because like that's the
laughing and dismissal kind of thing
I've seen him do it to people that are
like hey like people his constituents
yelling at him when he was on the
campaign Trail I remember him get up in
a guy's face one time he called him fat
didn't he and he challenged him to a
push-up contest wait who Joe Biden yeah
he challenged him to a push-up contest
he got in that guys you know what they
called him fat you know what's funny is
that Trump's actually been doing better
at you know one of the things about
Trump that's I know a lot of people
liked but a lot of people who voted for
him really didn't like was his Brash
attitude he was he was divisive you know
he he'd call people names he'd insult
them now what are we seeing from Trump
he's putting out videos that are just
like straightforward policy corporate
press is calling it a traditional
campaign or more so a traditional
campaign and Joe Biden is just laughing
about these problems like he's not even
he's not even planning on running anyway
maybe that's really it maybe he's just
saying he's gonna run but he knows he's
not even care what's incredible too is
they they had they give Marjorie so much
crap for how she acted at the State of
the Union because she called him a liar
but now he laughs in the face of this
mother whose two kids died
and silence except from Fox News he
laughs uh Hillary Clinton laughs
wickedly Kamala Harris laughs like an
idiot like like Hillary Clinton laughs
wickedly because she's wicked Joe Biden
laughs because he is demented and none
of those laughs are because there's a
big difference like it's none of it's
because like a joke was told and they're
laughing in response like Kyle Harris oh
my gosh
is the most witchy laugh I've ever heard
it starts off deep did you see the the
girl did the uh the Kamala Harris
impression she's like no no it starts
off deep
just think of us the psychological
makeup of a career prosecutor it's like
no eight years isn't enough throw him in
for 30. to beat have that amount of
power right now and to be laughing about
stuff is insane to me I I understand
humor we're human it's part of what we
are but like I think they're laughing
because they have no vision of of how to
solve these problems I think we should
just accept it though that's who they
are they're laughing at us they're
laughing at us while we die because of
problems they created that's who they
are oh you're mine that might have been
your mind popped out yeah what were you
saying say one more time oh I said
they're laughing at us and that's we
should just accept it this is who they
are they're laughing at us while our
children die because of problems they
created yep but while they're laughing
at us they're also turning around and
going these poor people in Ukraine don't
you care about the ukrainians and I'm
like I I mean personally I'm so
disconnected from what matters to normal
people I mean yes they're emotionally
attached to people in a country they
can't find on a map but their own
country they just don't care about is
this the most morally obvious thing to
take a stand on I think it's lowest
effort different than that though you
said they're disconnected I don't think
they're disconnected at all they know
people are starving they know people
can't afford to eat they can't afford to
live here and they're choosing to care
about these other things they're
choosing to laugh in the face they know
all these things but they're not
personally connected to it like I
remember there was this um Professor
from like Columbia or something who
years ago published a book about how
he's like a functional oh my mic is
popping he's like a functional heroine
user and he's he's not an addict he's
just a user but um he's obviously like
you know not connected to the experience
of people who in the opioid crisis are
on these drugs because uh you know
they're on the track to a death of
Despair and he's also sourcing his
heroin like in a way that's safe because
of his socioeconomic status
and uh then he publishes a book that
completely downplays the gravity of this
crisis because he's not really a part of
it you know
and he's also a libertine like a moral
academic so he doesn't have any morals I
don't remember what his name was he was
just some like Professor
um wrote a book that was basically about
like uh how he thinks that harm
reduction is uh the best solution to the
opioid crisis but also like you can use
uh drugs like you can use narcotics
safely uh if you don't have like
pre-existing mental conditions which is
he basically denied that
that opiates have a pharmacological uh
element of like addictiveness which is
obviously untrue so the doctor with the
dreadlocks call something yeah I don't
remember I never saw a picture of him I
just uh heard about it that's why that's
why top-down governance doesn't work why
central planning doesn't work because
you get you lose touch with the people
that you're not around you need to let
them govern themselves from a distance
you have to that's a mix man there's got
to be some plan for like National
Defense the original idea of federalism
you know there's a federal government
but it's fairly weak in the states
mostly take care of their own business
the problem is as a culture we're just
too different
I suppose if you go back to the the
foundings of this country most people
just want to be left alone and that
worked really well like if you're in you
know a new state or whatever you're like
look I'm here I'm doing my thing leave
me alone the problem now is you have
authoritarian ideologues in places like
California that want authority over
Texas and New York or you know New York
and California basically agree on the
same things so they want authority over
Texas and Florida so Texas and Florida
can sit there all day and night and be
like we we hereby agree to be left alone
and we'll leave you alone in California
goes you got it buddy and then as soon
as they turn around they go start
screwing with them so I I don't know how
you we we I don't know if there's a
classical liberal solution to the
problem we're facing right in times of
War
like I'll put it this way Anarchist
societies don't work right we can talk
about I think Catalonia the famous
Anarchist attempt at a country I forgot
what the story was but they try to
create this Anarchist enclave and it
gets crushed instantly by barbaric
outside forces if you've got a hundred
you know Guild members who vote on
policy because that's an anarchist
system everybody comes together and they
wiggle their fingers and then next door
you've got an authoritarian regime where
one guy dictates everything what do you
think is going to happen the one guy
dictating everything is going to say to
his his military crush them and then
when the anarchist people see The
Barbarians heading towards the city they
go we're under attack quick what do we
do and they're like well we're
anarchists we don't believe in
centralized planning so let's hold a
meeting and have a discussion on how do
we approach this this attack and then a
day later they're overrun and they're
all dead
you know you could have some kind of
mixed system where in times of emergency
they elect an Executor who can then take
over and become a temporary Emperor like
we saw with I think it was Cincinnatus
was was that yeah he was like right he's
like I don't want to be an emperor and
they're like well we're in an emergency
and we need one now to act with
executive you know emergency powers and
then after like what like two weeks he
was like I'm a farmer again I don't want
to do this and it's like it's like an
epic story but the issue is in times of
Crisis and emergency we fall into
executive decision making we don't just
sit back and say let's vote on it so
right now as we're dealing with a cult
ideological authoritarian authoritarian
and terroristic regime there is no
passive voting your way out of a
conflict with these people they're
firebombing buildings they're
sterilizing kids vote like there there
is no peaceful let's all come together
and have a decision no it's going to be
for now I think the solution is probably
hard legislation and law enforcement no
more you know we got to be we got to be
tell tolerant of the adult man thrusting
his hips in front of that baby no that's
a crime and that person should probably
be arrested in charge and it's about
time we stop passively saying we'll just
let him do their thing because it
doesn't bother us hey look we're here in
Texas and in Texas we have laws but if
California wants to do it that's
California's business that's federalism
and that's what people are arguing for
and I'm kind of like nah maybe the
federal government should be like
there's a standard and you can't have
sex adult sex shows for children so
we're going to stop that but but too
many conservatives are telling me that
Civil War is not gonna it can't happen
the country would be crushed China would
take over at Fair Point I agree and then
they say Federalism is the answer let
the states do what they want and I'm
like why so California can start having
sex shows for kids like they've been
doing that they're doing it in Texas I
don't see a classical liberal solution
to this there's going to have to be a a
centralized Baseline morality that we
all agree on so and then we enforce the
law and we're seeing it in California
now with the gender transition stuff
making that a safe haven for kids to go
to California so if you can can't get it
in Texas you can go over to California
and get like abortion right so so this
idea of federalism just means that
you're going to have states that do
things that are
morally abhorrent but you're going to
have two factions if you want to avoid
Civil War the answer is have the laws be
enforced at the federal level California
cannot just let illegal immigrants come
into the state and there's nothing done
about it the problem is is the selective
enforcement which is probably useful
because like marijuana schedule one
narcotic are you insane it's a it's like
a plant like don't OD on it but they're
obviously William Randolph Hearst wanted
to get that stuff made illegal in the
late 20s early 30s to get his paper
Empires Geo and all the trees he was
tired of printing on hemp he went to
print on his trees so he manipulated
Harry and Slinger and Congress to make
it a narcotic Federal one scheduled
narcotic that's insane and if the
federal government goes into California
to bust them up for selling weed I I do
not agree with that over reach of
federal yeah but that's something that's
debatable these issues like drag queens
thrusting in front of kids shouldn't be
now I'm I think it should be debated it
has to be debated now because of it
because the situation there should be
any debate I I'm not willing to have a
conversation or hear anyone's side on
why you think a man dressed as a woman
who's wearing a thong and leather
get-ups should be reading to our
children reading now we're not talking
we're dancing thrusting yeah they're
doing all of that so we we talked about
Bill Maher the other day he's got that
clip on CNN where he said the
transgender activists have gone too far
and there was a bit of context that I
think we missed because Jake Tapper says
yes but what the trans activist would
say is that now they're trying to ban
all of this stuff regardless of what the
kid or the doctor says and Bill Maher
says well perhaps that backlash went too
far well hold on there a minute Bill
Bill Maher actually said the Banning of
child sex change surgery went too far
when did Bill Maher start being in favor
of children getting sex change
operations he's because he's defending
it now saying no no no that's too much
that's too much we should allow that and
I'm just like within the span of a
couple of years like literally two years
we went from there are no child sex
change surgeries to they are but they're
rare to the backlash against it is going
too far and it should be completely
legal for all children the pain in like
two years the penis is incredible in
which this all became widely accepted
and it speak I blame cops but this is
probably part of the weakening of
Institutions to fund the police now you
have in Texas the famous story was they
were doing the adult sex show for
children where it said like it's not
going to lick itself and all that and
then the cops were like well you know I
can't get involved in this kind of stuff
and it's just like are you kidding me
there are adult men with fake sex organs
dancing for children with a big sign
since it's not going to lick itself and
you're just going to stand there well
you know they that they it's it's but
but they shut down that woman in Texas
for operating her Salon during covet yep
that's why I've been like a boss the
police
like look at all the major news that's
been coming out for for the past several
years why there was a woman who opened a
cafe in Minnesota and it was against the
covert rules so they hunted her down and
arrested her yet you can have adult men
with fake genitals thrusting in front of
children with a big neon sign saying
it's not going to lick itself and the
cops are like well now you know we can't
get involved in this and people are
alike back to blue baby okay actual
pride in this country and like its
founding principles have less and less
incentive to become cops and also
military service members so like
more and more it's just going to be
corrupt power hungry people in the
police force anyway but aside from that
like are we not gonna recognize the
relationship between like accepting
adult sex change surgeries
uh that starting us on the path to
accepting the the child sex change
surgeries like that's where it starts
well that's right the interesting thing
about that that I've been talking about
is
it's the one
uh DSM-5 disorder where we decide to
affirm right if your body dysmorphic and
you want to remove a hand we say no if
you're anorexic we say no if you're
morbidly obese well we're starting to
say yes to that I don't say we but body
positivity if you are cutting we say no
if you are if you have pica where you're
like eating pennies we say no
but if you want to remove your junk we
say okay and I have to wonder if it's
because there are people who are
thinking about like well you know they
won't have kids so that works out like
that's their mentality but I just don't
know I I'm genuinely asking why it is
that for all of the dysmorphic disorders
and all of the general DSM-5 disorders
the one we affirm is the one that
sterilizes people
you know like when someone's anorexic we
don't say go to the doctor and get your
ozempic and and your pills we say you
better start eating the doctor says
start eating the top two issues for the
Democrats right now are abortion and the
transgender affirming care
why why do we affirm this one you know
like I was talking about this the other
day I tweeted it when when someone they
they say like oh but if we don't give
them the care they're they're at high
risk for suicide and I was like oh yeah
that's called the 5150. if someone is
presenting signs of self-harm they get
involuntarily committed so they can
receive treatment to stop them from
wanting to harm themselves we try to
save them from this if somebody is
standing on a bridge about to climb over
the railing people run up and grab them
and pull them up they don't say well I
better affirm their decision why don't
you but they're starting too
yeah to accept assisted suicide and
euthanasia
I see people talking about accepting
mental illnesses as well like as just a
fact of your life that is not
circumstantial and you know if you're
depressed and you you know don't want to
get out of bed or brush your teeth then
you know that's a disability and you
should get government money for it
basically like that's that's a condition
you were born with did you see that
Viral Tick Tock where the the I think
it's a woman she's like why do I have to
work full time just to live
and it's it's like seriously that's
their attitude I'm like entropy I guess
oxidization your body falls apart unless
you do it's like that's because office
job work like normal Corporate America
work is kind of soul-sucking so I get
why she said it I gotta be honest if you
know I was about to enter the gates of
eternity and they said there's one where
you're sitting in an office all day and
one where you have to hunt and forage
for survival I'd go with the hunting and
foreign
food right what I'm saying is like if I
had to choose a life between
farming how about that and office work I
choose farming
space
the office work is pretty like it's a
fair point these people are going into
jobs and they're just like I sit here
staring and doing nothing but this
remedial Garden also overqualified and
like knowing too much is torturous uh
when like you're not really put to use
in society you're given this like
meaningless email job that you know is
useless and isn't a building block to
anything important
yeah of course people are going to end
up depressed and and they're going to
wonder like why am I even working
anymore yeah but they won't exercise the
Federal Reserve really wants people to
work this jobs economy where they're
like we need jobs jobs uh you dig the
hole now you fill the whole back up
we're going to pay you both with our
funny money and you owe us interest on
the money we gave you now go and that's
what they want they have people doing
menial almost sometimes even useless
literally hold dig it fill it up they
get fill it up as long as the key people
are busy I love this leftist meme where
they're like did you know that in
medieval times people didn't work and
they had you know what what do they say
like 50 days Utopia yeah they say that
the medieval peasants had like 50 days
of vacation and only worked like four
hours a day and stuff like that by the
way because they were religious they
observed religious holidays it's not
vacation but it's not just that it's
like
you know I I loved on the story of my
occupy friend who went to work on a farm
to reduce their carbon footprint they
lasted two weeks and they said it was
because they were working sign up to
sundown it's like you wake up you work
then you work until it's dark and you go
to bed it's like what happened with Chaz
they were like this is too much work
have an autonomous sound
or was occupied back to the Empire with
occupy their inability to govern yeah
they so with Occupy Wall Street they
tried doing the anarchist general
counsel or whatever and but when it when
it didn't work they were like okay we
can't we can't figure out how to find
unanimous unanimity unanimity unanimity
yeah something like that but it is
unanimous in order for there to be a
functioning Anarchist Society everyone
has to agree with minimal descent that
meant when they were trying to make a
decision you could have one or two
dissenters but it had to be like 95
percent of people in agreement and when
one bad idea got into that group it
spread like fire or had a potential to
and then all of a sudden you get 98 of
the people are like bad idea now and but
what ended up happening was you had a
handful of people who knew for a fact if
we don't get bins to store clothing
they're getting they're it's rot it's
getting soggy wet it's growing mildew
it's getting filthy and our food is
spoiling we need bins to seal this stuff
from the rain
and they couldn't get it done because
every time they would say we want to use
funds to buy bins they'd be like no
plastics are bad for the environment no
it's got to be recycled it's got to be
fair trade it's got to come from a
mom-and-pop shop and so they finally
agreed okay you can get the bins so long
as they're fair trade recycled not from
a box store and they couldn't find that
it was impossible so what did they do
they just went and bought from Walmart
or whatever whatever they could find and
then just didn't tell anybody because
the anarchist system just literally
didn't work you couldn't find it and so
when it came to that system being broken
a bunch of these facilitators were like
how about we create a new system called
the spokes Council well the problem was
it was a general assembly nobody would
agree they were like no you are not
changing the system because you can't
get what you want so then one day it was
the funniest thing ever they all say all
in favor of the new spokes Council
system and like two-thirds of the people
clap and then the third are like
blocking and saying no and the guy goes
let me count uh yeah we passed it worked
and then it was just like no it didn't
you're just saying that and people went
along with it because like what are you
supposed to do the guy talking said it
happened it happened the last night I
was at occupy at that with the council
we were working on they wanted to build
a decentralized Craigslist kind of thing
where you could send items to people
that need it like protesters and that
was the idea maybe that maybe a
technological solution is the way to
develop Anarchy I I don't know whatever
happened to it though decentralized
Craigslist yeah yeah I guess Craigslist
itself is not technically decentralized
on a bunch of servers but the idea is
you work with the seller you don't have
to go through a central portal so it was
a bit redundant Craigslist for
philanthropic causes yeah I was supposed
to be by the way the ransom Raves
section on Craigslist is top tier better
than Twitter yeah I love it maybe we
should make a show based on that
Craigslist just reading Craigslist rants
like the missed connections yeah
me and my friends used to make fake ones
I saw you at the studio but you were
deep in the computer we had we had one
where it was like I see you all the time
I saw you at work I don't think you
noticed me and then like it increasingly
got darker and darker where it was like
I remember seeing you walk home you were
so beautiful I don't know if you you've
noticed me but I want to give you my
number I was you know standing outside
your house I looked through your window
things like that just really funny but
uh actually that sounds like a really
good idea we should write that down like
commenting on uh Craigslist rants
actually writing it down yeah let's jump
to this story this one's a good one so
we have this uh fact check from WTHR
viral video of Biden saying he's
reinstating the draft is a deep fake in
the video President Joe Biden appears to
say he's reinstating the draft so the
U.S can help defend Ukraine against
Russian forces the video is a deep thick
I love that this was fact checked
because it was made by turning point it
was on Jack pesobic's show and he
outright says that it's not a real like
he explains we are showing you of what
is to come and it's like it's meant to
be provocative and then the media is
like oh people might think this is real
all right well here's why I think this
is worth talking about
election season's coming up we are going
to see deep fakes and they are going to
improve at the speed of Maximum economic
investment and they're going to be
hilarious yeah but some of them are
going to be scary but yeah hilarious too
like the one of Joe Biden and Trump
playing OverWatch which was one of the
funniest they keep making them there's
one with um Joe Rogan and Jordan
Peterson and then Elon comes in he's
like you sons of I can't I can't
fight the boss the OverWatch
no but the OverWatch one was good he was
like Jesus Christ I come in here try to
get a quick cue and it's bidenator and
it's Trump saying it but uh no what I
think we're gonna see is how much money
do they invest in presidential elections
it's it's a it's got to be what billions
billions it was it was I think Obama was
a billion so now imagine how much money
is going to be on both sides for an
election especially with how crazy
things are getting in this country
and they are going to be investing
people are going to invest tens of
millions into advancing deep fake
technology I guarantee it right now
some political person I don't care what
political party saw this and they said
if we can make this impeccable we will
never lose another election again
and so they're meeting right now with
deep fake companies saying and and I bet
a lot of it is is totally like
seemingly on the level some guy who's
gotten nefarious intentions goes to an
AI company and says hey I want to invest
a you know a billion dollars into the
development of the technology and they
go wow that's really great thank you for
the funding and what they intend to do
with it is make realistic videos that
are indistinguishable
and so my fear is
not that you'll see a video go viral of
Joe Biden reinsetting the draft why well
people are going to be like get out of
here he never did as a deep fake but
what they'll do is you'll have a real
video of Donald Trump say uh saying we
should condemn them totally referring to
White supremacists and neo-nazis and
what they'll do is they'll make an
impeccable deep fake replica where he
should says and some of them should be
condemned totally a very minor
difference but a drastic change in the
context and then you run it on CNN and
then if they get caught they're just
like we didn't know and not even no it's
not even that they're going to say
that's the video and then Trump's gonna
sue and say that is not what was said
here's the actual report and you're
gonna say look there's 12 different
videos all seemingly of the exact same
thing we don't know which one's the real
one because everybody knows Trump gave
the speech everybody know knows Trump
says something about condemning Nazis
but the only difference is they should
be and some of them should be it's like
a weapon it's like a strike first kind
of thing like well the ethics of
striking first is you know beyond me I
don't know what's going to happen is
Democrats will share the video of trump
going and I'm not talking about the
white nationalists because some of them
should be condemned totally and they're
going to go he said some of them like
he's implying all there may be some good
ones there and they're all going to
share it and it's going to infect that
bubble and then you're gonna get the
right being like no no he said they
should be who somebody all of them and
there's going to be two different
versions of one news event existing for
both different political factions so
it's going to be no different than it is
now that I mean that's very different
right I mean they're listening to the
same thing and having yes but you can
still so I I was a uh at a family
holiday event and I was talking about
how China was potentially getting access
to the DNA from covid tests and you know
one individual was like what get out of
here that's BS that's not true you can't
say that and then I just pulled up my
phone pulled up NPR reporting it and I
handed to him they read and they went oh
wow I didn't know that and I'm like
you're sitting here thinking I'm wrong
about this I was just I NPR of all
sources what happens when they go no and
they pull the video and they show you
the video and you go that's not a real
video they'll say you're a conspiracy
theorist and you're lying I have the
video
so what's the best way to authenticate
those though impossible defects yeah we
were talking about that today in one of
our development meetings I don't know I
think it's going to have to be either
the person verifies the video themselves
and if it's a video of you that you
don't verify then there's no
verification I think it's going to be a
lot easier to verify the real ones
rather than sniffing out all the fake
ones but then people like project
Veritas will try and catch someone
they'll be like no I don't that wasn't a
real video so you've got to be like at
some point
um the other idea is to build like a
headset or some sort of tech that you
can use that can see that it's a deep
fix somehow no that can tell if it's AI
you got you got you got to understand
the the full sphere of what this what
this means a video will come out of say
a guy at Pfizer saying something
ridiculous like we're mutating the virus
or you know who knows what yeah and then
what will happen is
a Veritas like organization will say
here's a video of the guy saying they're
mutating the virus
what they'll then do is they will make
using that video another deep fake and
say ah yes but here's the part they cut
out and then all of a sudden you'll see
another video where the guy goes could
you imagine if like someone from these
companies had something as crazy as
we're mutating these viruses so that we
can make more money that would be insane
and then everyone will go oh Veritas cut
the context out he was talking about how
crazy it would have been if someone did
it no he didn't actually say it wow that
proves Veritas is lying you see the
point I could see that in other cases in
a case like Veritas they they I mean
they have all the footage
yeah but how do you prove a negative if
an organization to defend itself deep
fakes your video you can't prove the
video doesn't exist you can only prove a
video does exist so you'll get a video
of trump saying something like you know
we're gonna build a big beautiful wall
and then the left will you'll get a
combination of offensive and defensive
deep fakes the left will make a video
where Trump is like saying something
somewhat offensive to add context making
it seem like he's racist and then to
defend against it the Republicans will
add another bit where Trump is saying
can you believe what so-and-so said he
said this and they'll just keep trying
to change the context with defects
think about what happens if you you get
filmed and someone leaks audio of you
saying something offensive you can be
you you can say hey that's out of
context that I wasn't actually saying
probably wasn't so if Ian came on the
show and said I don't like buttered
popcorn and that clip went viral people
would be like wow he doesn't like butter
popcorn if Ian said no no that's bad he
would just make a deep fake of him
saying I would never say something like
I don't like buttered popcorn and that
inverts the context and that's what you
can do with the fakes too it's going to
be wild man a billion dollars per
campaign plus and how much of that money
can get invested in making stuff like
this remember the meme Wars in 2015-16
it ramp it up baby because you're going
to get a combination of you're going to
get subliminal liminal and super liminal
deep fakes super liminal defects are
going to be someone being like and
here's a new meme of Joe Biden singing
The Chicken Song and it'll just be Joe
Biden it'll be silly then you'll get
stuff that are liminal I'm doing air
quotes a Simpsons joke that are more
like what Jack besobic did where it's
some people might get confused by it but
he says what he's doing and then the
subliminal is when they just leak stuff
and then don't say anything about it and
people fall for it they should do one of
fetterman
I mean that'd be cool but it would just
be here yeah how would you how would you
know if he if they released a deep fake
of fetterman right now saying look
here's your proof of life exactly
and then what happens when get this
John
hodgkinson runs for Senate
and everyone sees videos of him staying
at the podium cheering everybody sees
interviews with him talking about his
policies
and there is no John hodgkinson it's a
AI deep fate character
that appears in the media that appears
on YouTube that does this campaigning
and you'll see people in YouTube their
cheering form he'll have commercials
where he says vote for me because I
believe in making America great again
and that everyone's like I'm gonna vote
for this guy and he's not real I think
you made a good point that if if
fetterman had a deep fake uh because
when when they did fake Biden it's
obvious it's a deep fake a lot of times
because you you can't hear the
imperfections like you can't hear the
degraded quality in his brain
um and a lot of times when people do
perfect yeah and when people are singing
with songs if the machine builds it you
can kind of tell it's like robotically
perfect and so there's this imperfective
quality to human behavior that possibly
cannot be captured by a computer if we
could somehow perceive that in certain
contexts I at least agree with that yeah
I think it will be though and that's
what's scary is I feel like the
technology is evolving a lot quicker
than we are I feel like we're pretty
dumb compared to what we've created
people a lot of this chaos is coming
from because we are not equipped or
evolved to live in the world we create
those videos of like Jen's ears being
like why do I have to have a job they
are going to be the first in line to go
into the pod
they're going to say you know you're
right about this you shouldn't have to
step into pod where we will hook feeding
tubes right into your gullet and then
put the VR helmet on and you'll live in
digital world where you can be whatever
you want I thought you meant the suicide
Booth well that too created that
mentality by making it so miserable to
live and survive for these kids I mean I
do gen Z gets a bad rap for being so
nonchalant about it but wouldn't you
you're never gonna own anything most of
them are not going to own houses or cars
or anything
so I don't really blame them I've been
lied to about most things
um and especially like the gender stuff
like think about being a Ave them on
hormones working at Starbucks and
they're like 20 mobile orders like I
wouldn't and then you have like social
anxiety disorder and stuff and like they
all have disorders I mean it's just like
it's not an enviable position it's
boring I agree with that but like you
talk look at people come back from the
jungle after losing a leg like I don't
see
combat vets complaining and bitching
Adrian Curry says send them to Ukraine I
agree that's the thing and all the tick
tockers to Ukraine any any one of these
people who wants to leave Ukrainian flag
and complain about what's going on I say
we send them right over
you know like it's it's hard I do agree
that life has become treacherously dull
for people especially being lied to
about the military-industrial complex
and then realizing you're part of the
Empire is like what the what am I
doing I mean the reason they wouldn't go
to Ukraine is because they're like
languishing the fact that they know
they're useless like that's that's they
know that they that they would instantly
die their situation and that's like
demoralizing even worse
how much you want to bet winsinger that
story of you will live in the Pod you
will eat the bugs you will own nothing
and you will be happy they're probably
going please it can't come soon enough
they are they are I will tell you gen Z
has that attitude you know I I see a lot
of the dialogue especially when they're
talking about you know if there was an
apocalypse they're saying wow you guys
will to live is incredible I just let
I'd let it all happen so I think these
kids are severely depressed I think they
don't really have much purpose because
we've hyper fixated on individualism and
this narcissistic Society so these kids
are just focusing on only themselves and
they have a meaningless life because
they have no other purpose except
themselves so once we took away that
Community not even themselves yeah yeah
well the future's sounding pretty good
huh I imagine kids are like the ultimate
purpose I because I've been gaming a lot
and just keep thinking like what is the
freaking purpose of life I keep rinsing
and repeating the same thing there's no
goal there's no like quest to salt to
finish there's no experience gained I
don't get the ding when I do the thing
it's just non-stop abominable human
spirit and like the the drive to produce
the Next Generation to do what though
eat more candy bars and watch more TV
like what because that's what I'm going
through and I think having children is a
big part I haven't done a space
Explorations for some people see see my
my dreams for the future cannot be
accomplished in a single lifetime you
know I I am not driven by having a fancy
car or an infinity pool I'm driven at
the thought of a spaceship traveling the
Galaxy with a bunch of people on it
being like you know we're 17 light years
away sir engage warp you know I wish I
could find up there
you know maybe maybe
people get bored of that too like I've
tripped my balls off and seen the
craziest stuff and and like experience
the most
I mean bending reality and it's still
just like now what like even while I'm
tripping I'm like okay the bug is
dancing on my arm what is this all
things will die and I'm like crying
relationships
nothing nothing technically matters but
for me it's all about negative entropy
my mind things matter just watch helping
other people because what matters is
creating more organization is is
organizing free energy into complex
systems that's it I feel really good
whenever I feed bucko and he's happy
like the cat that I've been taking care
of someone would you go to Mars if Elon
told you you can get on a spaceship
right now and go no you wouldn't nope
would you you said you want to go on a
spaceship I didn't say I wanted to go on
a space
cringy when they shoot themselves up
into space and then just come back down
like you didn't really do anything you
just sat there Mars right now looking at
spaceships getting shut up and you're
like it's a one-way trip if you go to if
you go to Mars you're staying on Mars
for the rest of your life would you go
orbit Mars and then come back I'd go to
them probably not it's like an
eight-week Journey or something humans
humans don't understand how much of
their life is nothing but humans I mean
it's like you've got to remind them go
out into the middle of nowhere and see
how much anything matters you'll care
about your survival but you will start
begging for humans well that's that's
community and people
it's social media but really we've been
so divided and our neighbors have been
demonized and everyone's your neighbor's
going to kill you if they take off the
mask it's just very we lost that
Community a long time ago this is why
solitary confinement is torture yeah
with my friends air quotes on the
internet I have 1800 friends on Facebook
how many friends do I actually have in
life 13. it's a false sense of community
that we get on social media yeah family
is like the major components I think
when you get older you care a lot less
about when you're in school and you have
a peer group you're forced to be around
them you are told by the system like
here you're doing this thing it's either
school or work and so you have friends
because of this confined space but when
humans are set off to be on their own
they focus on family which is moving
down instead of you know your peer group
is is to your left and right your family
is the generation below you you'll care
a lot more about that and you'll strive
for a lot more for that than you would
just friends as you get older family is
the is the human component that people
need that's why you were just saying man
like you don't get the double mean hit
if you had a kid you would and that's
why it's crazy you get that Chelsea
Handler video where she's like I don't
have kids so I get to wake up do drugs
and masturbate and I was like that
sounds like what a 16 year old would say
lady it's not just that but it's her
implication that having children is
humiliating yeah that's so weird yeah
and that like living for pleasure is the
only way that uh that a woman can like
reach uh her potential like I mean I'm
sure you actually like having become a
mother understand that's like very
demeaning when that message is
constantly pushed oh absolutely that
that's you know you're you're free
that's the best way you can live is not
having children my kids is the best
thing that ever happened to me but I
also understand that it's it's getting
tougher to have families you don't have
that Village anymore to help raise kids
yeah and so a lot of these things too
seem so silly that are in the news and
stuff because you you have people who
can't raise families the way that we're
supposed to you it's not ideal
circumstances to have families and I'm
fortunate enough that I can provide but
a lot of people can't and I understand
that they don't have that Village they
don't have the community they don't have
the economic resources so it's kind of
two-fold where you want to promote
family values and tell everyone to have
families and that's your purpose but
it's also very hard for people to do
that now so I hear a bunch of people
trying to take a kid away from you as
well I see both sides and yeah exactly
you send them off to school you send
your son to school and you come back
with a daughter it's daycare it's school
it's gender transition that word care I
don't like that word care man like what
what's caring about daycare like are
they really being cared for they just
call it care yeah neglecting care and
the abuse in those places
mind-blowing like I yeah and also elder
abuse is getting worse the most
vulnerable people in our society are
being abused of our community yeah
exactly have you been able to find the
tribe or yeah and I'm fortunate enough
to have a good support system but I
think that's where conservatives kind of
fall short is that you know you push
these Family Values but they're not
really pushing any legislation or
policies or changes to make it easier to
happen
and for families to survive
so I do think that
Republicans tend to play on the defense
instead of offense and they're not
making pro-family policies they're not
making it easier for people to find that
purpose I found with all the cool people
I'm meeting doing this show that I
haven't really made any friends out of
it like I'm Jack besobic I love you jack
I like you love Jack he's cool he's like
if me and him hung out we'd be friends
but I don't see him and like I'm
realizing the community like the
community part of it is missing for me
that's what I haven't been doing lately
it's like I've been able to talk to you
dude this is your fault I know every
therapy yes everybody comes here and
they're like I hung out at Tim cast
castle for like three days I never saw
you in once and like we're all
downstairs we're at a Super Bowl party I
just said he didn't see you for three
days yeah a lot I love you yeah
I started making internet videos in 2006
and I was like I can be friends with
everybody I'm gonna do what Jesus would
have done if he had this Tech and then I
got burnt out I was like I can't I
started to become friends with people
that were depressed and then I would
start to get depressed and I was like I
gotta I can't be around other people
because they're freaking me out and
because you use the tech
what is that is that not why it was part
of it I was meeting people from all over
Earth random people that I had nothing
in common with that I was taking in
their behaviors and and idiosyncrasies
and values and things before I even knew
who they were and I would get like
demons I mean they're they're like the
darkness and Humanity would start to
seep into this drug induced lots of weed
that's probably part of it too is I
couldn't control myself my emotions
because I was so open from my neurons
all going at once here's what we're
going to do here's what we're gonna do
in we're launching that show poker with
the boys all right and it's it's it's
meant to just be like a a boys show hang
out it'll be girls there too it's not
just boys but like the general idea is
to hang out with your friends style
podcast where people are smack talking
ribbon on each other probably talk
whatever is in current news but it won't
be a news show like this and you just
gotta come to it what another problem
I'm having maybe people identify with
this is I I don't like small talk I'd
just rather be silent and sit in silence
with someone which is very awkward it
depends what you mean by small talk I
think like small talk is part of
recognizing the the Dignity of the
person in front of you
you know niceties are also kindness
so small children feel welcome
Hospitality just more like just more
just understand I feel like people who
say I hate Small Talk are actually not
like not you Ian but like they like are
the people who who call themselves
sapiosexuals and stuff like
you're not as deep as you think you like
small talk is deep like you're
recognizing the person across from you
elevate the conversation if that's your
issue Ian if if someone's like so what
did you do yesterday and you're like I
had lentil soup and like oh yeah how
does that go let's talk about philosophy
and quantum physics uh have you ever
read about String Theory just it's
somewhat odd but when people it'd be
hilarious I think we'll try it I'll try
it and like everyone says this but you
like talking to you is uh an intense
experience because like no one pays that
close attention to me like anyone
talking to you just feels like whoa
um you're like actually looking me in
the eye and listening to what I'm saying
and responding accordingly like that's
that's a rare experience in human
conversation and it's a good thing you
think it's becoming more common
no I think people look people are
disassociating from each other yeah and
they're they're spending more times in
Virtual spaces in virtual reality and
video games and things like that they're
not having kids I got I gotta tell you
there there are
there's professional athletes and
musicians that I'm a huge fan of and I'm
like they got no kids but look look I'm
gonna be 37 in a week I don't got any
kids either that's kind of crazy to me
and so you know private business but
there's an intention for me to have a
family but there are a lot of people I
see who are now in their 50s that I grew
up watching and looking up to to a
certain degree have no families at all
and I'm like that's it that's the end of
their their genetic influence their
their legacy ends with them now there
there are a lot of people have kids
don't get me wrong a lot of people have
kids but there are just some rock stars
and pro athletes and I'm just like man
they just didn't have any families that
kind of bums me out because it means
like the the the life lessons and the
genetics the combination of these things
that made them who they were great
people that had a tremendous positive
impact on the world gone yeah with them
gone and I'm not saying their kids are
going to grow up to become famous or
anything they might you know be oh yeah
you know and that why is what
I'm interested in why do we have so many
people making choices that really are
against our biological nature most
people given the ideal circumstances I
think would have children and families
so why are there so many people
my original thought was I got really red
pilled no 607 and I felt pretty alone
but I was like okay I'm gonna have to
make a self-sacrifice I'm gonna have to
let my body be destroyed in order to
speak up against the military industrial
complex they're not going to have it
Jesus got killed for it I'll probably
get killed for it that was my role in
the dice I'm like I don't have kids
because I don't want to leave them
fatherless and that that was kind of set
me on the last 15 years but I'm at the
same I don't want to leave them
fatherless but I I'm not gonna stop
talking I I we refuse to back down and
maybe I I don't know you know when uh
people say like I don't want to bring a
kid into this world like the world is
just such a scary place and it's only
getting worse
um like how could I subject someone to
grow up in a world like this
um and like yeah there are unique
factors to like why living today is
different maybe worse in a lot of ways
but um I think people are just afraid of
uh you know being the person with the
biggest impact on a on an impressionable
person like I think it's they're afraid
of passing down their own mediocrity I
think it's also just a really scary
world true to raise a kid in like we're
fighting to not have it always has been
pole dancing in front of children sure
sure but we had a cold war with like
nuclear weapons in Cuba kind of so it's
been a harsh world yeah it was harsh in
a different way I mean they are really
trying to take our children from us is
what they're I mean they are stealing
the innocence of our children does that
same thing with the Vietnam War yeah you
know we yeah I mean communism was
spreading like crazy we've uh we've
talked about that whatever podcast quite
a bit uh which they have these clips
going viral and there's one I love that
guy what's his name Chase Chase was the
second guy based yeah that video where
he's like you you know I don't want to
bang a dude or whatever but there's one
where there's a woman saying she doesn't
like talking stages I saw that one she's
referring to like the wait three days
before calling kind of thing is that
what she's talking about no a lot of
people were giving sort of grief because
she wasn't very articulate but I think
what she was saying was actually kind of
she's upset that gen Z really doesn't
have traditional dating periods it's
you're just kind of hooking there's no
definition to anything so in a way she
really was yearning for that hey maybe
you should go back to like traditional
she wasn't able to articulate maybe it
took her 60 seconds to articulate that
one sentence but and and by the way it
must be like kind of a Purgatory to have
that stunted level of uh English you
know but yeah I did understand her point
I think it's also hard for her and like
other gen Z people to say like hey
people are only hooking up with me now
nobody actually wants to she genuinely
doesn't understand all right here's the
video people are giving her bad faith
advice
people I don't think the audience will
be served at all by hearing this but
I'll play it for you anyway yeah like
annoys me and like the whole dating
world is like talking stages
like that shit's so annoying like the
whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing is just like what what
specifically just like the fact of just
like you like
I don't know how to word this
like in like talking
I can't do it I can't listen anymore I
should have left the first time I tried
to but I've since listened to say she's
speaking hot girl language so she's
saying that the in the early days when
you're texting back and forth for like
and then it turns into a week of texting
and then two weeks so then she she goes
on to say like no one wants to commit or
be in a traditional like dating right
these weird talking stages and their
talking stages mean like the hook up
phase and you're seeing someone and
she's also talking about 21 year old
dudes who go to college in California
like here's here's what James Lindsay
said she's crying for help because of
the damage online dating and hookup
culture have wrought speaking vaguely
and badly about her tacit knowledge of a
miserable you wanna pull that up uh uh
speaking uh let me start over she's
crying for help because of the damage
online dating and hookup culture have
wrought speaking vaguely and badly about
her tacit knowledge of a miserable
circumstance without the vocabulary to
articulate it this is sad yes what I got
you can see I even I retweeted it too
James is smart fella when I got from it
is she's basically like she wants a real
relationship with somebody yes and that
doesn't exist and uh it's feminism's
fault because basically the sexual
Liberation thing told men you have to
you there's nothing you have to do
anymore there's no responsibility
there's no resources there's no hard
work ladies just gonna give it up so
when you end up with a bunch of little
boys who sit around playing video games
all day and don't have to provide
anything women who don't want families
so you so the guy doesn't have to
provide anything and there's no strings
attached in hooking up and now you have
women and I'm not saying every woman I'm
not saying Muslim at least in this case
one woman who is like this sucks yeah
but it's not just I feel like this is a
majority of the Gen Z girls and the the
whatever they're calling that other
generation they really fell prey to this
hookup culture and I think a lot of them
and you see it here in her even though
she's not saying it well they're
understanding that it's not making them
happy and that's why I feel if we had
someone that wasn't you know Andrew
Tate's great right the way he articulate
relates this to young men hopefully he's
innocent but he's innocent he's going to
be charging well you know you want to
preface it but you know he does see
these good things but we need Andrew
Tate has not been charged with any
crimes yes so it's like what's he's not
even he's not even there's nothing to be
innocent um
that's my little disclaimer but I like
what he has to say but I think there
needs to be a version of that that is
palatable for women that's saying the
same thing but palatable for women
because they feel the same way but the
way that it's put for them is just off I
don't know the only way to to beat it is
to not participate it in it like the
only way to get rid of hookup culture is
to just stop hooking up with people and
I'm sorry but most of the girls on this
podcast on this podcast whatever are
hooking up with people they're making
the problem worse and they're not
willing to take accountability I think
that's why a lot of people are like
angry when they see this clip because
they're like I mean I don't know this
about this girl individually but like
the archetype uh you know she's
contributing to her own problem and also
Andrew Tate is a participant in hookup
culture so it doesn't really resonate
when I hear him talking about the
negative effects he's not like people
say he's kind of like what do they call
him uh kickbox Mai Tai Jordan Peterson
well yeah but doesn't Jordan Peterson
more traditionalist and like clean your
room have a family with kids Andrew Tate
is like get all the ladies you know yeah
yeah I guess Peterson walks well
technically Andrew Tate is more
traditional than Jordan Peterson because
Tate brings it back to a you know carnal
more primitive State Peterson says don't
lie and Andrew Tate says I lied for
money I had women pretending to be
talking to guys why dudes doing the
typing we made tons of money we we ran
the game like he's just a liar and proud
about it so they are not on the same
level in any way I agree with you that
being alone is less worse than being
with the wrong person so like these
people doing hookup culture maybe they'd
be better off if they were alone but
those being alone and being in the wrong
relationship are like demon
the alternative isn't even being alone
it's just like dating in a normal way
that doesn't immediately like for these
women give strange men access to your
body you know what I think it is for
both sides I think it's a cultural
deficit in that we created all of this
media
iconography TV shows about love at first
sight and about you know a guy meeting a
girl and they just love each other or
Hallmark movies where you know the
woman's in a relationship with the guy
but he's snooty and she goes back to her
hometown and there's the old you know
football player and you know the
Lumberjack The Lumberjack and he's and
he's he's a stand-up honorable guy and
in reality relationships are built
together you you you meet each other you
get along you say okay you start
building things together and you build
up that emotional bond over a long
period of time it's also like young
people seem to think that it's like you
meet someone and it's like they're the
one no met them if you are in your best
place and you meet someone in their best
place then you will realize together
you're something but they're not going
to make you better you gotta you gotta
be up there so that they can come up to
meet you I I made that mistake for a
long time thinking she was gonna fix me
and well so what's advice you guys would
give to young guys because I think a lot
of guys are afraid of rejection sucks
and getting rejected in public if that
gets blasted out on the internet not
only you might even look like a predator
a kids are probably guys are probably
afraid of that so what advice also need
to learn to reject guys in a way that's
gracious and not ruthless you know
that's a problem what would be that's
cool what would be a good like advice
for for young guys that want to
pursue a relationship with the girl in
this modern technology era
that's a very loaded question I mean I
think it depends what they want you know
if you're a young man looking for a more
traditional relationship you go to
church yeah yeah I mean that's really a
lot of people say that but it's like
okay you're gonna go up to someone in
church and be like hi like that wouldn't
be very trapped make some people feel
weird they say the supermarket I didn't
mean to interrupt you no you're fine but
I I just feel like they have to they
have to live you know you have to walk
the walk and you can't be calling for
traditional Lifestyles if you yourself
are involved in hookup culture and
things like that you know if that's what
you want really Tim's not wrong you're
going to find that in church or a
supermarket that's the other thing no
for real they say you know guys will go
to a bar to pick up chicks and it's just
like I guess that makes sense for a guy
but for for a woman it doesn't make
sense because you're gonna get a guy
who's not looking for any kind of real
relationship that that's what this young
woman is basically saying she comes to a
point in the video where she says like
this is not gonna lead to a real
relationship and then there's another
video going viral of a Japanese woman
who was surprised when she met this
guy's family and she was like so this
guy I've been seeing him we went on five
dates he introduces me to his family and
I'm thinking like wow this is a really
big deal like we're hitting it off and
then when she inquires he's like no no
we're just friends and she was like what
like that doesn't exist where she's from
when a guy and a girl hang out several
times they're dating when they introduce
their families to each other it's very
serious in America dude look the first
thing about feminism I don't know if
Japan has their together either
well sure dating oh yeah absolutely they
have the hickey kimori where the guy
yeah hikikomori the guys locked
themselves in their rooms and play video
games all day and never come out even
when their friends are like outside
there's in their room playing video
games and no one ever sees them and then
uh but that's Japan uh I forgot what I
was going to say I was gonna say
something about oh yeah feminism
I know that the the woke left us are
going to be like you know Tim Poole
blames feminism in cell blah blah blah
and it's like look man I don't care
about women running for president I know
we end up like I think actually let me
pause what's your stance in the 19th
Amendment actually repeal
I think there have been a plethora of
problems
there you go we like we have women on
the show and they're like repeal the
19th and it's always the guys who are
like well I don't know I'm like if the
ladies vote for it but anyway I don't
care about that stuff feminism wants to
see women as CEOs I don't care run a
company do whatever you want like I can
choose to go to business do business
with whoever I want you can run a
company if you start a company but in
terms of like the sexual Liberation
stuff it's not really Liberation it's
stripped women of their leverage in
relationships women women were told you
can go around and sleep with whoever you
want and the guys were like yes I love
that you're pointing that out about
leverage because when they call men in
cells they're saying you can't get
access to sex with women but like sex
with women has become valueless now yeah
so where'd the leverage go is that even
an insult anymore well so the thing
about installs is most of these guys
it's an internal problem it's never been
easier for these guys to hook up you go
to a bar buy some drinks everybody gets
you know has a good time they're drunk
they go party and then for or you know
it that's tough that's a risky and
modern culture because you for sure you
blast it out on the Internet it's
putting your hands on someone's thighs
I'm not saying they don't touch women
without consent but they might think
they're it's consensual and then they're
taking a step too far I think that's a
big problem there is a reason why bars
have the lights turned low and there's a
reason why there's that that you can
bite it like Hot Topic or Spencer's or
whatever it says beer making ugly people
attractive since you know like 900 like
is it I've always thought the one of the
cringiest things of the guy's like can I
kiss you now and they're like oh God
just go for it
so should the guy ask before he makes a
move I I don't think it should be
mid butt I think whoa
absolutely they have to
see see they're women
this is actually perfect I don't even
know how do I how do I look this story
back I had it pulled up and I'm like
okay
she was emotionally groomed guys yeah
what's her what's her name uh what's her
Megan Hall was that her name let me try
and find this one Tennessee cop I don't
know it is funny though because a lot of
these feminist ideologies mostly benefit
men all right take a look at this this
story went viral and I have no idea why
about this Tennessee cop Megan Hall
she's now claiming she was sexually
groomed and that she said no and they
wouldn't take no for an answer or like
one guy wouldn't or something like that
they colluded in their authority to
systematically disarm her resistance and
entrap her in degrading in in an abusive
relation sexual relationships exploiting
her felt trapped so you want to talk
about guys in the modern era if a dude
is with the girl and the girl comes up
to him and puts her hands on his
shoulder and leans in for a kiss and
kisses him he just assaulted her and if
she wants and she says it they're in
trouble this is a story that went viral
for months about a woman who was banging
a bunch of cops and just was as Loose as
loose can get and now she's claiming she
was victimized and they wouldn't let her
they wouldn't so what did she say that
it was one that I mean so she was fine
with the other seven and not well she's
saying she was groomed she was saying
they they groomed her
and if you're an adult are you are you
getting groomed really no is that an
adult police officer is now complaining
about being grouped in all honesty
you're supposed to be the law
enforcement of the land like turn those
guys in what the hell's go you're a
grown adult professional with
professional equals quote I did say no
and he wouldn't take it for an answer
okay so is this that sounds like one is
this a story about this cop who was
being abused this female cop and just
didn't know what to do or is she a wild
and crazy cop who's hooking up see see
do we know I don't know I'll tell you
this if you've got a young guy
even if he asks well she can just say
she he didn't and then he's he's going
to jail he's getting locked up it is
very scary and like you know I have
younger brothers I have a son it is
scary for them dating now and Chappelle
talked about this with uh he did that
joke where he had the guy sign a consent
for hit part of consent form and then he
was just like now hold on there he
climbs off of him he's like let me just
fill that out initial here and sign here
and just make sure everything's good
because that's where things were going
and the funny thing is that show was
like early 2000s and then it was the
2010s when we got mattress girl this
woman who begs a dude to hook up with
her reportedly and he doesn't want to be
with her finally they hook up then he
leaves and he's like I want to be with
you she gets mad about it and then
carries her matches around claiming he
raped her even though the messages show
that she was begging him
so when Ian asks should a guy ask can I
kiss you yeah your best bet is meet a
girl at church and have a real
relationship and get married and all
that stuff otherwise you go to jail or
something but going to church to hook up
going to church no the confession Booth
no one can see that if I worship loud
enough what I'm saying is meet a person
in a real environment and have a real
relationship it's tough to do a lot of
it's like uh what do they call it happen
stance like you walk by and you see her
like that not anymore dude now we got
that five hours of walking through New
York as a woman if you even say howdy
ma'am you're considered assault you're
assaulting your cat calling what about
that whole Home Depot thing I said to go
they said to go to Home Depot and find a
guy in Home Depot because the guy can
actually fix stuff so like there's a
good place to meet a man if a woman
wants to run into a married contractor
I went to theater school and I met at
other actresses girls that I and that's
how I got my first real serious
girlfriend because I was pretty nerdy so
look if you're a woman
and you don't take advise me I'm some
dude and you want to meet a guy go to
Home Depot and then just make sure
there's no ring on the on the hand and
then just you know say I'm trying to fix
a door can you help me can I
hired so many DIY projects your way in
the relationship but no like if you're
at Home Depot for a real reason you
gotta have a problem fixed you're gonna
find a better quality guy oh they're so
happy to help too every time I don't
know what to do I'm like I'm just gonna
ask them how to do it can you reach that
they're so happy to help there but not
just that like guys like solving
problems and being helpful if a woman
goes to a guy and says look I I gotta
fix a door and I need somebody who can
help me do it you know a guy might be
like that sounds great I could totally
help you with that that'd be awesome
yeah I'm here to help do you think that
uh dating apps should be deleted from
people's phones or should they keep I
think it I think that and social media
contributes to the problem of people
always thinking there's something else
out there well you know I could do
better and that's just comparative in
general with the lives that we're living
but it absolutely contributes to it I
noticed that I was in a relationship and
I had kept Tinder on my phone and I
would still find myself looking at it
from time to time well what if I need it
you know it's that hole it might be
something else and so this last
relationship I'm in right now I deleted
all the apps right away it was just I
knew like getting into it and what uh
there's uh you can always reinstall it
you know it's not like it's gone forever
let's make a fake dating app where it's
like all of the people on it are Bots
and they just they say nice things too
you know there's like a conservative
dating app now I don't remember what
it's called but like uh Christian right
stuff right stuff it's something like
that but like that just means you're
gonna find hyper political people who
are just obsessed with politics which is
not what you want either there's
Christian Mingle right that's like it's
been around for a long time there's
plenty of fish J date I always pardon me
want to get a J date I'm not even Jewish
it feels so dirty just like join us a
Facebook group of people who are
interested in something it was like a
fantasy kind of thing just like join a
join a Facebook group people are
interested in things and then go to
things go to events people need to talk
to their neighbors and find local
community oh you meet people through
people that's a good way to do it that's
a great way to do it that's what it used
to okay so so think about something
something you're interested in and then
go to events of those things and meet
people the problem is when it comes to a
lot of when it comes to a lot of of uh
Hobbies or crafts and stuff it's dudes
it's not women like true Ashley you're
right about arranged marriage yeah I
just wanted to put that out you know we
need to bring that back yeah really
those clutch what's your favorite I mean
think about it think about like the The
Stereotype of like the older woman who
is always trying to like match make
younger people that doesn't exist
anymore because she's bitter and single
she hates younger women she doesn't want
her to find love
right okay that archetype of the
matchmaking woman in a in a village you
know it doesn't exist anymore yeah but
what if it's like a matchmaking probably
because she has a family and wants me to
have a family the problem the problem
with arranged marriage is that it's um
it's anti-meritocratic in that you might
have a three-year-old boy and a
three-year-old girl and then they're
like we're gonna our kids are gonna get
married when they're older and then by
18 the the male is like 100 pounds
soaking wet frail they were rarely
arranged at such a young age but it's
not forced arranged marriage is not
forced marriage then how could it be
arranged you're allowing the parents to
judge the merits of the other person
yeah because they're older and more wise
so you're saying like when a woman is
about to become an adult or whatever the
parents decide oh we found this guy for
you get married to him like guy's
parents are involved it's not full it's
not arranged the families are it's just
like a mom suggesting a guy like honey
you should marry the guy across the
street
families and working it out love is
organized anyway you know I feel like
the obsession with like marrying for
love as well is very hyper
individualistic yeah there's a lot of
different type of Love yeah and it's
kind of yeah you know
if you're like I love this sandwich so
much like what what kind of love I think
love is also a choice and not a feeling
in a lot of ways I think people too many
people equate it with a feeling that's
what I was saying like people like I
think our generation and younger are led
to believe because of movies that you
know you walk into a a bar and there's
like a beautiful woman and it's like
heart to be still I'm in love and it's
just like yeah and then you find out
she's like a white supremacist you know
and you're like whoa I don't want to be
here like she's attractive but not I'm
not going there you know like you sounds
like this has happened to you no I just
mean like you see a beautiful woman and
it turns out she's just like messed up
there could be like a pretty lady and
you're like wow she's beautiful and then
she's like the people from the Moon have
stolen my cheese and you're like okay
I'm getting out of here or you know I
don't know maybe a guy who's into that
kind of crazy wild ride maybe she was
using candies with Ian for a moment I
think you go to the Moon bro you find
someone that you have things in common
with where you can have fun you can get
along and you enjoy each other's company
and then over time you build a
relationship you said it was a choice so
like how to find that I mean you choose
to love people I think
um even your family and people they they
don't always act in ways to choose to
will the good of another yeah yeah so
the choice being like like you're
letting you're accepting the downsides
of the person yeah I mean as long as
they're not abusive or toxic
um all the crazy people just need to be
with each other and then leave all the
same people alone yeah there should be
like a crazy people dating app Oh you
mean all of them for all the rejects
yeah Tinder is one of the worst too what
are your favorites like what are your
top three I've never used them I had
Tinder Bumble and Okay Cupid did you
ever use any of those I was on Okie who
but a long time ago I got it at first
because I was building mines and I was
like we were gonna add a Tinder thing
into the thing so me and Bill were like
hey market research let's get it and it
was so addictive I'd spent hours just
like swiping I'm like I am this is the
most superficial stuff I've ever done in
my life I'm judging these each
individual human we don't even need it
anymore with all the data we've
collected an AI can just be like boom
this is your match you're done the AI
I'm not even arranged okay
yes like I arranged I guarantee I
guarantee you this I would bet a large
sum of money that if you took all the
data from all the dating apps and then
plugged in the data to like an AI the AI
could find your match instance of Black
Mirror yes sir and then you'd be like
because it knows you're where you're
from it knows how old you are it knows
how much you weigh you could do like one
of those history I mean if you want to
put actually but I'm saying you can't
account for your personality yes it can
because Okay Cupid does that thing where
it asks you all the questions it knows
when you poop so it can like be like oh
yeah Facebook
do it Facebook check it out that's what
it was supposed to be Facebook would
understand things about you in in weird
ways like
you don't need to tell Facebook you're a
conservative Facebook can see your post
where you say manga2024 you don't need
to tell Facebook that you enjoy peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches because you
once posted posted an image of a blue
circle and it seems completely unrelated
but there will be weird things like that
where statistically people who like
peanut butter and jelly for some reason
are more likely to post blue circles
than red squares and we don't notice
those things but the AI will because
it's looking at hundreds of millions of
Internet interactions and then finding
statistical correlations so they already
do that there's um you know if you buy
turkey bacon you're more likely to vote
Democrat and these political parties
already use different data like that
that's really scary the amount of data
have you ever looked at your Google
profile yes yeah or if you drive a
Subaru you're more likely to vote
Democrats would be a lesbian yeah but
that's obvious that's like oh we get it
somebody who likes turkey bacon is more
likely be left leaning but what about
something like you you uh uh go to
McDonald's at seven in the morning oh
you're more likely to get oil changes in
the third of the month at 7 pm like
weird things that we can't see it will
find those correlations and tell you
that means in dating apps if it took
your social media profile all of your
data
we could easily at this point make an AI
that would be like here's your perfect
match I think we're getting it in terms
of attractiveness in terms of location
in terms of personality the AI would
break it all down and be like based on
the people you've messaged based on the
people she's messaged based on what you
like and don't like the times you go to
the bathroom and the food you eat you
should get married I feel like Tick Tock
could do it too I mean The Tick Tock
algorithm is insane so sometimes it's
scary how hyper uh fixated it is on your
life and your interests and everything
like that so I think that could come
very soon how much of a relationship do
you think is about shared
um interests
like how important I think it depends on
the interest I think it's more important
to be have shared values
rather than interest I think interests
are temporary and could be switched out
and changed and I'm not interested in
the same you know some of the same
things that I was years ago but I think
values is more important
yeah I'd agree because it's been like
sometimes it's fun to you know be dating
somebody and then they have a different
interest you don't always want to do
just the things that you know you want
to be exposed to new things you don't
want to just have exactly the same
interest as somebody else because like
what more is there to talk about after a
certain point you've already seen all
that so you've already done all that
stuff it's like yeah it's very surface
level yeah right I agree shared values
being like morals ethics kind of thing
yes yes
I mean especially I used to tell people
that all the time when they'd ask oh
should I you know my girlfriend's a
Democrat I'm like well get out how does
that happen I I don't know and that's
what I said I said there is a
fundamental difference in the values of
Democrats and Republicans that's that's
not going to work I mean what happens if
she gets pregnant first of all you know
there's just like I can save her I can
fix her that's what it is well I mean
that's partly true women who get married
tend to vote Republican but it could be
because women who have Republican
leanings are more likely to get married
you know the marriage may not be the
Catalyst it may be the inverse so yeah
you never know I guess but I will tell
you Millennials seem to be extremely
unhappy particularly Millennial gen Z
and younger women they have very high
suicide attempt rates very high
depression and anxiety so there's no you
can't come to me and be like no they're
happier than ever women not
statistically they're miserable it's
nuts because like it's the hottest girl
I mean that girl is beautiful who is
talking like this like this and and she
doesn't have a boyfriend are you kidding
me like if I was
why would a guy
do the extra work and make himself
monogamous with her when feminism says
he can have her and all the other women
all at the same time why buy the cow
when you get the milk for free and
that's what feminism did it
you know what a shotgun wedding is yep
that was because dudes would go bang the
girl in the barn and the father would
run with the shotgun and be like uh-uh
that was my daughter now you're married
and the guy was like oh shucks the meme
was that the guy didn't want to get
married he just wanted to hook up but
there were moral obligations to a woman
women had leverage now it's all free
baby she's like okay nothing because of
uh you're like she should have a
boyfriend she's attractive I mean maybe
20 30 40 years ago but now a guy hooks
up with her and says I can call her
whenever I want and she'll be there
because she wants me and I don't have to
give her anything oh my gosh but that's
a good thing well not her not to not
give her anything thing but call her
whenever you want kind of thing that's a
good thing except she wants him for men
to be in a relationship and he doesn't
have to be she needs to take
responsibility and not hook up with a
guy thinking that it's going to convince
him to commit to her I understand yes
yes yes I understand except this woman
says to the guy hey I want to be in a
relationship and he goes lady I got 50
women on Tinder right now saying the
opposite of what you're saying see ya it
depends on what he wants yep I use there
are probably a lot of older guys who are
like I want to have a relationship very
young guys who want relationships too
it's just it depends on uh I guess your
maturity level I used to be like agreed
uh get to know the girl with my best
friends for like a year then we became
boyfriend and girlfriend for like seven
years after that we were already best
friends and then after that didn't
really work out and then I just was like
you know if she's not gonna have sex on
the first date I'm not interested and so
that was how I you said that to her to
myself I was like from now on while I'm
dating if she doesn't want to hook up
then she doesn't want to hook up and
that was my mentality and I found a girl
for four years didn't work out you know
uh the recent girl feminism
it's true how so like fourth wave
feminism yeah they they have to put out
yeah that was amazing because it's like
exhausting like does she even like me
like why is she not having sex with me
I'm 34 years old like I don't have time
maybe it's because I was just getting
older and like I'm still in that date
with still in the dating pool that like
I don't wanna I don't want to wait and
see on this one like is it happening or
not well let's ask the audience we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com head over to
timcast.com click join us we're gonna
have a Live members only show where we
expand upon many of these ideas we've
got some pretty dark subject matter for
you tonight and it's going to be
uncensored and not so family friendly so
that's why it'll be on timcast.com but
let's read your super chats I'm not your
buddy guy says I'm not your guy friend
I'm not your friend buddy
I need Jesus says Matthew 24 4-13 to
Timothy 13 through 2 or Timothy 3 1-7
and John 6 37-39 does anyone know those
or there's a reference to no I I just
registered that as a mess of numbers ah
yes it's a Bible verses I want to thank
everybody for for letting me uh
empathize with Neurosis that I think a
lot of kids young people are going
through I'm actually in an extremely
awesome relationship at the moment so
you know I'm not not really nervous
about myself but I'm I'm allowing myself
to freak out a little bit all right a
little bit yeah
let's read some more Rusty Shackleford
says would IRC happen to be in the
running for members only chat protocol
now that Discord is out for the moment
no the Discord is almost done and so
we'll go with that and we'll see what
happens but um IRC was a really funny
idea it's a good idea the problem is we
just have to create like a new IRC
server every morning or something it'd
be kind of weird and then anybody could
just share and give access to it so
we're trying to do is create a system
where if you're a member at timcast.com
it gives you access to the Discord which
is relatively easy to do but uh yeah
agree I don't trust Discord however I
will say like we're not banned from
YouTube so I'm not super worried about
getting banned from Discord
I just don't like it and when we were
thinking about doing a different service
yeah they're probably worse so we'll
figure it out
all right Damien Master says yo you hear
Discover card is going to start tracking
their customers gun purchases wow oh wow
really well I got rid of mine so how
about that
yeah that's a whole other private story
so
Corey Alexander says Ashley Saint Claire
is on so this episode is going to be
based AF as it was as it was
Matthew Schneider says Biden fetterman
2024. it's a no-brainer oh yep that's a
classic That's a classic
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
man the fire in your eyes at Wesley's
Trek mistake I thought a dropkick was
coming hilarious the Chinese spy balloon
skit with Taylor it burns I'm still
giggling keep him coming yo yeah so uh
check out cast Castle on timcast.com and
uh we've got another one that we're
planning that I'm really excited for
basically we're just there it's a it's a
combination of their sketches right
we're doing we're doing sketches at Mock
cultural issues so you know and then
there's gags in them you guys gotta
collab with the bee I mean that'd be
great we'd love to go out with them so
uh Ian Ian did a really funny sketch
where he was the host of a show called
Rhian with Ian and he's basically
Crowder and then he's complaining about
his contract with Roberto Jr the rooster
and he's got it's called was a play
school rock and robot where he secretly
recorded Roberto's con The Roosters
conversation and you know that's my
resume I think we should make we need a
hit movie basically we I say like is in
this movement political movement I don't
think of that political terms but we
there needs to be a hit movie that's not
out
this system of daily wire Babylon B Tim
cast all these cool networks make like a
hit like Lethal Weapon hit movie I'm
pitching it to Crowder I haven't talked
to him I don't know where he's at I
haven't seen him in a month oh wait we
could easily do a movie
we just need a good script and uh six
weeks I think I think a comedy a
political comedy movie would be would be
great because the budget can be low and
then we would just reach out to people
like Ryan long you know he might be I I
don't want to Babylon be well yeah of
course I'm just saying we get a bunch of
people and then we could do like a funny
funny movie Ryan's hilarious too yeah
he's so funny yeah he was great on Rogan
I need to watch I've only seen Clips oh
is he on yep yep yeah good for him yeah
he had one funny one I'm not going to
say maybe I'll dirty jokes dirty jokes
all right here we go Fiji merman says I
had a her she bar I was expecting plain
chocolate but I took off the wrapper and
saw giant nuts
that was a good one
all men thesis stay alive John fetterman
we only need your corporeal form indeed
MF damius is Hardcore depression after
major accomplishments is coming the goal
doesn't give meaning the chase does once
you have it what now messes people up
that's why I firmly recommend to
Children skateboarding there was a great
article I read when I was younger it was
called what now and it talks about how
in skateboarding you'll go to this stair
set big says very tall you're going to
jump down and you're trying to do a 360
kickflip off of that stair set and land
it and it's your dream trick it's the
hardest thing you you want to do it
you've tried it a couple times you've
bailed finally you come back with your
friends you're like today's the day and
you land it and for about three seconds
it feels good and then you stop pick up
your board and it's gone
now what what what now it's over do it
again double no do it again won't give
you that feeling yeah another metaphor
is like playing Magic the Gathering when
you build your own deck and then you win
it's so much more fulfilling than just
getting a deck from someone and winning
like having created the the value I
think so I'll say this value for me with
skateboarding it got to the point where
there's like nothing left for me to do
I've been skating since I was about uh
13 and uh all the tricks I've wanted to
do I've done and there are some things
obviously like I'm not the best
skateboarder in the world there's a lot
of things I can't do I'm never going to
do like a kicklet Twist or anything but
I've never been passionate about that so
all the things I want to do I've done
gotten the dopamine release and now I'm
like in my mid-30s and I'm like I like
skating you know I'll do some tricks
here and there but I have no desire to
do a Nolly heel flip crook you know big
spin out or something because like I did
that when I was a teenager like the
feeling isn't there anymore so now it's
mostly just about cruising around doing
some big Ollies getting a few kickflips
seal flips maybe a few good flip tricks
some you know late flips in skating the
mini ramp and just cruising around
carving hitting some grind so you get
the flow of things and it feels good you
get the exercise but that drive to like
I don't know you know switch flip blunt
is just not there anymore what if Elon
said he wants you to come kick flip on a
spaceship
there's probably better people that you
could ask to do that yes you Tim then
would you go I mean I guess you know
okay
flip your way to Mars
it would be weird like how would it
would be weird to do a low gravity
kickflip I don't know I can't imagine
but I'm just saying like as you get
older when you're young you see these
things and you're like I I want to do
that so bad and then when you're older
you're like yeah I did all that stuff
Tim Cass SpaceX collaboration we make a
music video in space on one of those
re-entryable Rockets or we'll go up in
one of those maybe it's really
interesting that the article you were
talking about for the skateboarding was
called what now yeah
what now yep Matt Kinder says I'd love
to play a game of magic with any of the
cast members do any of you have an arena
account do you have an arena I think I
do I don't use it though I don't play
that online I have a a really good idea
we are going to with the poker with the
boys show it's uh we're getting a poker
table but it's really like a tabletop
table right when you play Magic the
Gathering with your buddies use a poker
table because it's a card game and we
can do board games but I had this really
great idea of doing two things
the internet plays Magic the Gathering
the internet plays poker here's what we
do
we get five for magic maybe we get five
six players maybe maybe that's too many
maybe four but one player
takes actions based on what the audience
and the live chat is voting on
so they'll show the cards we'll need to
make like a real-time system where
people can get an app and then see the
cards in the hand and then pick the
actions they want and then whatever the
most actions get voted on is the player
will do you could have it like um you
show the cards in your hand one two
three four five six seven and they just
put the number play play card number and
then it tracks the percentages and then
what happens is
there's a thing called priority it's my
priority right in Magic and so when like
someone plays a creature if you have a
counter spell priority goes to you you
ask the audience they spam it you give
it five seconds say okay
yeah I thought that would be fun and I
thought uh like we could do with a bunch
of different things poker board games
create an app where people can vote on
what to do and then see if we can get
like a pro magic player to beat the
entire internet did you guys see the guy
who built a software program where you
can play pool on a video game and it
controls his pool stick and shoots the
actual pool and then he has a camera on
his table
all right let's read some more Smeg says
brain dead is actually used in the
medical field but the term is actually
called Death by neurological criteria
really
is that is that a nerd I'm kidding son
of a Murph says Ian removing the DNR
would make the everyday person have to
pay attending during the election Cycles
pay attention yeah I I we've been
talking about it for a long time yes
because then they're gonna be like vote
Democrat and they're gonna go who's that
get rid of it if they don't know who
they're voting for they shouldn't be
voting for him
good luck figure it out we did uh we did
it we did a cast Castle sketch where we
had MTG play MTG that with Ian Marjory
Taylor green played Magic the Gathering
and she's fantastic she beats Ian and
Ian gets really mad and he's like okay
and then he's outside she actually
played she didn't it she doesn't we told
her what to say and she performed it
perfectly oh I love that I just love
when she's like Ian plays Wrath of God
and then she Taps the blue and she goes
Mana drain and Ian's like oh
people who know that means find it funny
if you don't it's esoteric got it in one
take nice job yeah she did a great job
yeah we gotta really I wish I could tell
you the joke for the one we're doing now
but it's too good so I can't it's like
we're gonna put it up on YouTube and
everyone's gonna laugh when they see it
I just I can't I'm gonna stop there you
actually Thomas Martin thinks Tim
definite plays white green cat deck
no I play uh red white and blue
red white and blue baby those are my
colors America shocking uh one of my
favorite decks is red white and blue so
there's kind of car yeah nasty but
mostly blue uh it's control so that's
the color for you know control you can
see the red magic come out of his eyes
sometimes when he's getting fired up
yeah so red is like chaos and aggression
and so I like playing red and blue which
is chaos and control it's a mix and then
uh you know it is what it is so let's uh
read some more what do we got here some
more super jets Clint Torres says I
think fetterman is in for an
experimental treatment and one day is
going to come out in a press conference
rip open his suit to expose the Superman
symbol and yell hey you guys
look man they've got stuff okay let me
just say stuff
for it's like eight thousand dollars
stem cell treatments we got bocus the
cat stem cells to save his kidneys and
it seems to be working you think they're
gonna do that for fetterman I think
they're gonna let them maybe they want
wither and die I don't think they're
giving them any stem cells maybe they're
saving that for Hillary Arrow Kane says
use locals for your members chat
um maybe but we we need more than that
we we uh with Discord you can do Collins
yeah it's right a little deeper yeah and
we can create different rooms so we can
actually create like the VIP lounge
Elite access you know or whatever and
it's like I'd rather have it be based on
like time frames like you become a
member and then if you've been a member
for a certain amount of time you move up
in the the the you know rooms or
whatever yeah they'll be like the VIP
lounge and it's like if you've been a
Member log in three months then you're
in the VIP lunge I wouldn't want to do
anything where it's like over a year but
maybe because then it's good for us it
encourages people to stay members for a
long time to to go in these rooms you
gotta show respect to your veterans
that's right and we'll put Ian in the
room oh my God yeah okay we'll put Ian
in the VIP lounge but I'm only gonna
chat with video or audio I don't want to
do text and it'll be like if you've been
a member for at least a year then you're
in the room with Ian as he's playing
video games that's pretty cool yeah
all right son of a Murph says Donald
Trump Jr has bank account canceled news
what really what is that let me let me
pull up the old Don Junior Twitter
account Chase
it was Chase Chase canceled I don't know
I said I bet it was Chase let me see all
right
PNC whoa what PNC Bank shut down the
bank account for my app mxm news without
any explanation
what
you give a speech this is a quote you
give a speech at one insurrection
it looks like that's a quote I knew this
was coming is that what he said I knew
that's the quote from
alternet.com whoa
that's crazy debanked at the beginning
after being told to call a generic
helpline I was informed by the PNC
representative that per the terms and
conditions PNC reserves the right to
reevaluate their business relationships
at any time and terminate accounts
without cause well you know just started
a bank John rich
Donald Trump Donald yeah that's scary
this is what happens this is what
happens and this is why and I know a lot
of people are going to disagree with me
here but I was very concerned with the
compulsion to disavow Kanye because he
had just been banned from Chase Bank and
that to me no matter what he said is
really scary
um and but conservatives even if they
had never said anything even remotely
similar to what Kanye said they had this
compulsion to disavow the Deep banking
had been a thing for a long time before
it even happened to Kanye and it set the
precedent that that's just oh we got we
gotta I gotta read this one's a good one
Eric Christensen says I have a question
to ask about the title of this episode
rumored the title of the episode is
fetterman rumored brain dead and okay
figuratively he's brain dead literally
it's rumored that he's brain dead okay
so we can call fetterman brain dead if
we mean he's just not functioning
properly but in this context it was like
the rumors that he's literally in a
chair drooling and going and like not
functioning anymore but uh good Super
Chat very funny
all right what do we got here
here in gaming news says I can hear Luke
going re when Tim said Annika Society
doesn't work
uh it's not an opinion it's a fact every
attempt at an anarchist Society has been
crushed militaristically I'm not saying
it's not ideal or that we couldn't
implement it in the future I'm saying
historically every time there's been a
community of anarchists they've been
crushed by outside forces short-lived a
bunch of people sitting around being
like let's vote on how to deal with the
the uh the insert the uh the Insurgent
hordes that are storming into our
territories and then by the time they
figured out hey gone
so there's always some kind of mix
there's always some kind of executive
it's when the executive knows that it's
it's uh dangerous situations is when
they're needed is when they create
dangerous situations so that they're
needed that's when that's when the
Anarchy needs to step up let's just make
it Michael malice
call it good
Red Run Red Rum Max Red Rum access funny
how Ian has on his Twitter pin that he
will build muscle this year and yet and
yet is as sickly looking as ever it's
February no it's March it's March and
you look great I'm not healthy just a
parasite I need to clean cleanse my body
fix my dental work I just had a tooth
break today like I need to fix my teeth
I'm like the United States I'm like a
shell that's like not being kept up
probably not I've been taking care of
myself I haven't get enough sunlight
just just put on the muscle suit and
don't come on the show and you know
there it is but I I really need to to
purge my body of disease or whatever the
hell's in it right now yeah yeah so if
you're okay
I feel like I'm living in pain but I'm
desensitized to the pain so I haven't
been realizing like my jaw hurts like
almost all like constant pain all right
Thomas side bottom says in the age of
deep fakes the in-person campaign tours
will become incredibly powerful no more
basement campaigns
yep
James Madison's Ghost says AI deep fake
videos will become the fake news
headlines that get Shadow changed a day
later after everyone has already read
them misinforming people foreign
yeah man the Trump example of justifying
white supremacists is exactly it they
will make a deep fake alter one word to
make it sound worse and that's all
liberals will see
welcome in the future
tanyan says you're very optimistic about
this there are going to be Bots
automatically feeding news stories to
the AI skewed in their favor to have
instant deep fakes created as the
stories pop up
yup
so we are using uh AI for timcast.com
news articles
when there's a story we're taking we're
not all of it sometimes he'll just get a
picture of the guy when we're making our
own custom art for everything but some
of it is AI deep fake in that like we
did a story about Pete booty judge and
the train derailment so our news team
just AI generated a Pete booty judge art
with a trained around an art and that's
what we use for the story it's not a
real picture no one would confuse it as
being a real picture because it looks
like a painting but we're using AI for
the characterization of these things
I wonder if photorealistic art AI stuff
should be should be watermarked or
banned no you'll never be able to ban it
free speech
free speech to me you say something I
don't know about that I don't know if we
did the Star Trek joke in this cast and
the cast cast Castle episode but
considering it's already out anyway I'm
going to say it but um
we took we uh Captain Picard and data
and deep faked a conversation between
the two between the two of them where
data accuses Picard of being racist
because of disparaging remarks about
Klingons
and and you know my brother made a funny
joke about it I don't know if it's
actually in the episode but I but that
was that was an idea I had where I was
like if the gag is the camera comes in
the room and I'm sitting there watching
Star Trek then we can make Star Trek say
whatever we want on the TV yes oh yeah
so it's like I'm sitting there watching
the TV and you can see like the the
Enterprise fly-in and then it cuts to my
face and you hear data being like I just
can't quite figure out how to give it to
her properly sir well data you have to
try and thrust thrust you know things
like that and then I'm just going like
this is a good episode so we can do we
can make any show say anything we want
oh my God yeah we could like we and we
should just do it all the time because
it's hilarious
but this one was particularly offensive
so I don't know if it made it in the
episode I don't know but all I know is
if it did it was hilariously edgy it was
good I'll talk about it in the members
only show
all right where are we at Matthew waddle
like Adam Saleen the AI leader of the
Rebel movement in heinle uh heinlein's
the Moon is a Harsh Mistress the book
was written in the 60s
interesting
all right where are we at
ewape says need to start attribute
attributing a cryptographic hash to
metadata of official videos can't use
legally if the hash doesn't match public
key
nope because they're screen grabs
because there's compression uh because
there's downloads so you can try and
attach metadata tags to things but there
will be as soon as Trump gives a speech
there will be 15 versions of that speech
on the internet figure out which one's
the real one and they'll and what
they'll do is the fake ones they'll get
meta tags too and they'll say no ours is
the real one then you'll get nefarious
actors that will film it deep fake it
look like actual press will be at the
event they will film Trump speak then
they will deep fake alter it put a meta
tag on and be like that's the real one
here's proof a picture of me at the
event what do you do about it
what are you gonna do maybe Supply the
original meta tags and be like this is
the original this is the earliest date
if the dates in The Meta tag I don't
know if that stuff can be forged if you
have a technical solution you think you
do hit me up on Twitter with it I want
to give a shout out to uh it's I think
it's Mel and Rye rock paper scissors
anime is amazing video I talked about
this a little bit I think earlier this
uh uh YouTube channel Corridor crew they
used AI technology to turn themselves
into anime characters
so in order to make an anime battle it's
uh anime rock paper scissors two
brothers fight over the throne by
playing rock paper scissors and it's
actually really funny like when they
Rock Paper Scissors Shoot there's like
wind and like the windows all explode
and they're like uh but uh they filmed
themselves in a green screen then used
AI to convert that into anime then they
took photorealistic like uh environments
from uh Unreal Engine I think converted
that to anime to like animation style
and then made this show without actually
drawing anything that's yeah
but but we're not gonna it's in my
opinion still rudimentary I think we're
a couple years away from you typing in
make me an anime about two brothers
fighting over the throne and it will
just start rendering and then it'll be
like come back in 10 minutes boom here's
a 15 minute episode
it's gonna be crazy because I'm gonna be
like write a sequel to The X-Files movie
where Mulder actually discovers there
are aliens and then I'll watch it and
I'll actually enjoy it
yeah I'm thinking like
it's going to be less about making the
best piece of art and more about making
consistently good art because so there's
going to be so much of it that there
might be flash in the pans if this is so
great that's so great but the really
great ones are going to get reused and
re-copied and reprinted over and over
again so you just need to be known for
putting out lots and lots and lots if
you want to make a career in it I mean
all right what's that an art and digital
art baby leg Bennett says Ian the
meaning of life is to Simply live a life
full of meaning now please roll me a 77.
okay
oh no no that doesn't count it fell off
this thing never stops rolling it's
quite circular oh where's it going okay
it's rolling is it gonna be a 77 and
it's nope nope excited to keep going you
guys ever do a Ouija board where's it
it's gonna fall off wait wait no I
should 75 whoa close one it is 75. wow
sorry next time I'm I'm getting better
that's why I wanted to raid this one
because I'm like if he rolls this and
actually 77 comes up but 75 that's
that's only two two points away man
that's pretty cool that's a fairly
accurate it's all right there the price
was wrong the price is wrong
all right Carlos y says Ian the purpose
of kids is to set them up to have an
even better life than you you don't want
them to just have what you have but to
exceed you I half agree
uh you want in order for kids to have a
better life than you they have to
experience hardship to become strong so
a big mistake a lot of people make is
they raise their kids and say I want to
give my son the things I never had so
I'm going to send him to a good school
and I'm going to buy him a new car and
I'm going to give him all these things I
wish I had and it's like bro you are
successful because of things you didn't
have giving your kid all this stuff just
means it's going to be entitled to older
and be like why won't the government
give me a new car so what you should do
is when you have your kid bring them out
to the woods and you know teach them to
fight and punch trees and start fires
and like campfires I mean obviously and
you know survive not not start forest
fires fire no no none of that none of
that
all right
Cowboy Redux says the internet has
already destroyed politics long before
deep fakes politicians do not do their
jobs the only virtue the only virtue
signal on social media the people that
vote for them live in a spectacle
economy inundated with depravity yeah
but let's be real before the internet
you'd get people like Hillary Clinton
and they'd go to New York and be like
hey you gotta vote for me because I'm
just like you guys huh you know vote for
me yeah then they go down to Alabama
black you gotta vote for me because I'm
just like you whether they go to Chicago
and be like you know if you vote for me
I'll get your garage door opener fixed
in no time
that's what Hillary Clinton was doing
because internet video wasn't a thing
when she was younger so she went down to
like Arkansas or whatever and started
talking with a Southern drawl and it's
like oh please New York Senator Hillary
Clinton AOC did the same thing it's like
she has no you know she did the Latina
thing listen yeah it's not as bad as
breakfast tacos from Jill Biden oh yeah
jeez
all right what do we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Ian sir please
stop blaming 2006 YouTube content
hey man don't knock it till you try it
put your put your emotions and your your
truth honesty and your face on the
internet on video after video and listen
to people and make responses and create
Community try it it's not easy
get them in all right let's grab uh
we'll grab one more Rio Super Chat what
do we got Let's uh let's see a good one
neglectful sausage says I've always said
Star Trek is racist AF in Next
Generation Picard says like a Romulan or
like a Klingon to people using racism
insult DS9 was the same
well okay well yes that's that's a good
point and you should watch cast Castle
to see the bit we did because it's
basically that so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
over at timcast.com by clicking join us
and in about 10 minutes we'll have the
live uncensored after show up for all of
you to hang out and we've got some
pretty dark stuff to talk about it's not
going to be family friendly so you're
being warned you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Ashley do you want to shout
anything out just uh The Babylon bee and
you can buy my children's book elephants
are not birds at brave.us
people find you on Twitter yes at
Sinclair Ashley
you can follow me on Instagram or
Twitter they're both merry archived And
subscribe to pop culture crisis we go
live at 3 P.M Eastern Time noon Pacific
time every Monday through Friday and we
talk about celebrities movies all that
stuff good show I've been on that many
many times uh you guys follow me Ian
cross on anywhere on the internet pretty
much everywhere on the internet any
social network and I'll see you later
and I am answer.com on everything on the
internet I've seen a lot of people
playing with SoundCloud which is
interesting thanks
tomorrow at 1pm over at youtube.com
timcast we will have a hangout interview
slash conversation with Pete perrotta
formerly of The Offspring and we're
going to talk about the issue he faced
with the vax mandates how he was
unceremoniously removed from The
Offspring after 14 years and I gotta
tell you guys crazy story
so uh Pete has been in a bunch of he's
been in the uh two of the music but it
was out of three we've done so far
technically there's four but uh two of
the ones we've done recently one's not
out yet it's it's currently being edited
and he came out here we filmed he's
amazing he's an amazing drummer it's an
honor and a privilege for me to uh we
get to work with you know the drummer
was with The Offspring for 14 years
because they were my childhood favorite
band but he's never publicly done an
interview about what happened with being
kicked out of the band because he's a
very humble you know and kind of quiet
guy but uh I asked him if he would want
to come on and talk about this and and
give us the full picture oh and talk
about a bunch of other things and he
agreed so we're going to be recording it
tomorrow morning for the culture War
podcast episode two but here's the crazy
story last night after this show
I go home and I'm getting ready for bed
and I press power on the TV the only
thing I press
and because usually I watch Like
Yellowstone 1983 but I finished watching
those so I watched some movie last night
so I I go into my bedroom and I turn the
TV on throw the remote on the bed going
to the bathroom take my contacts out
when all of a sudden I start I start
hearing kill boy Power head an offspring
song and I'm like what and then I walk
out and Allison my girlfriend she's like
did you turn this on and I was like I
turned the TV on she and why it was it
was The Offspring playing at a rock
concert playing the song kill boy
powerhead and Pete's playing the drums
on the show and I was like oh look it's
Pete and then Allison's like you didn't
turn this on and I'm like all I did was
turn the TV on I didn't turn a channel
on I didn't turn open Amazon I didn't do
anything I just pressed power
so I have no idea why that turned on
but it was just kind of crazy just on
the TV that's real yeah part of the
algorithms manipulating us to see what
the machine creators want us yeah I
think it's the Ouija board but all I do
is like sometimes Synergy is real it's
like God like spirituality and I'm
afraid that people might might lose the
the distinction between algorithmic
manipulation and God actually moving
people together so look normally when I
turn the TV on it's static like because
you get the home bar it's like an LG and
like the bar pops up and if you get you
got to pick HBO or Paramount or whatever
and usually it's like Amazon I turn the
TV on this time and I didn't think twice
and then it started playing a rock
performance from The Offspring which is
weird because there's Smart TVs that you
if you turn it off like it resets you
have to go back to the app that's that's
very weird anyway when you do the wheels
we're gonna we're gonna go to the one
we're gonna go to the members only show
uncensored at timcast.com so and also
check out the culture War podcast
tomorrow at 1pm youtube.com timcast
thanks for hanging out we'll see y'all
there